I think Breaking Bad epitomizes
everything that I guess does not
interest me I prefer the later seasons
of Game of Thrones [ __ ] oh God genuinely
welcome back to this episode of trash
taste I'm Connor with the boys Garden
Jay and today with a special episode yes
only fit to be viewed on the TV hope you
are chromecasting this or you have a
built-in Chromecast in your TV Apple TV
the point is it's going to be on your TV
because this is the TV episode we talk
about some of our favorite TV shows of
all time and roast each other's tastes
we're going to be picking nine shows
each and then we're both gonna be
raiding the other persons three by three
babies
because I've missed the three by three
format you know I've missed it because
we it's been actually like a long time
since we did our last three bites what
was the last three by three weeks I
think it was like music right music
that feels like a [ __ ] eternity
I like what's better than just talking
about [ __ ] that you like you know and uh
just not arguing every like five seconds
about I mean we are gonna be arguing you
had a lot of difficulty picking your
list yeah yeah yeah because I it wasn't
until I was making by 3x3 I realized I
didn't really grow up watching a whole
lot of like variety of TV yeah
um so I really I had to actually text my
sister to be like what the [ __ ] did we
watch growing up because I legitimately
don't remember so how can I see that
good TV if you don't [ __ ] remember it
well no I remembered it and she reminded
me because we were both like uh what the
[ __ ] was it what is my favorite TV show
of all time I couldn't tell you I can't
remember it no no well actually it's
it's I I had a similar problem to Joey
in that I haven't I don't think I've
actually seen that many TV shows yeah
right yeah or like seen it down to like
the end or have like an emotional
attachment yeah like there's lots of
that I've seen But like they haven't
really stuck with me or they've I don't
really feel that strongly about them
yeah because let me tell you the
difference between like a TV show and an
anime anime 24 episodes one season you
can binge that in a night if you wanted
to uh you start a TV series and it's
like hey here's nine seasons of 24
episodes that's an hour long true and
that's like that's like a you know a
fairly middle length TV yeah if you talk
about some of the most famous TV shows
like Breaking Bad or something that's
Five Seasons That's so short in terms of
like I mean for Americans
right so so the the rule uh is that we
decided to not include any anime because
we've already done an anime
um we can do it was like a mix of
basically it was like any TV show right
so it's like a mix between like Western
cartoons like uh narrative driven like
TV shows like just TV programming we
used to watch literally anything series
yes episodes yeah and so basically
anything that's not anime because it's
not anime and a movie I can name off
more anime that I've watched than whole
than the entire broad spectrum of TV
shows in every country I feel like my
list or gaunts List uh could easily have
been my list I'm pretty sure I know what
God's gonna put on his and I I could
have put them on mine but I was like
God's gonna put them on his so I'll let
go and talk about it mine's gonna be
some weird [ __ ] I hope so when isn't it
Joe when is
[Laughter]
this I definitely felt more like a
casual coming into this like than a lot
of other I watched the most TV out of
the three of us probably probably
yeah because like I discovered anime
really early I discovered anime really
early in life so I'm like why would I
need to watch TV when I have anime guys
come on I don't know like you know
sometimes anime is great but sometimes
you need you need like a bit of Jack
Bauer 24 in your life to like spice
things up yeah I mean like yeah I I get
that as well and I like that one of them
that's not one of them that could be on
my list really I love 24. I don't think
I've seen a single episode of 24. 24 was
like the thing I watched when I was 15
I'm like this is so [ __ ] I know enough
about 24 through osmosis but I've never
sat down on any episode is the uh
movement of uh water particles by the
way
yeah
but it's about wow do you mean the
future did you just come actually
yeah I mean like there's a lot of TV
shows that I've watched like I've
actually seen 24 but I've only like I've
only seen one season of 24. I've seen
like three four seasons of Lost I've
seen two seasons of house but like it
takes up so much time I've watched a lot
of TV but I've been a commitment yeah
I've never I've I've really done in my
student days yeah I've already finished
TV shows right up until the end just
because there's so much
yeah that's why I had a hard time
choosing fair enough yeah well should we
leave it to trash station
space is like almost gone yeah it is
a battered Warfare yeah all right who's
going first
I don't know who's gonna go first
oh it's you it is you Connor I guess
that works all right all right Kai bring
up Connor's three by three all right uh
for those of you in case this is your
first time you're watching a trash Chase
3x3 video we should do a quick
explanation what a three by three is
basically it's as the name suggests it's
a box three squares by three squares
nine in total and it's basically nine
whatever the the topic is in this case
TV series that you feel strongly about
or you grew up with or you really enjoy
you really like you want to share so
these a lot of these are some of my
favorites but maybe some there's a good
story behind it all yeah that's what
it's helped me yeah yeah basically
you'll get a good idea of what that
person's personality is like based on
their three by three yeah that's mine
that's mine
before starting can I just say this is
the worst cropping I've ever seen
I did not care to hand mode
Kane is there any way we can see God
[ __ ] on the top of the bottom dude I
can't even see the title of Mad Men
because it's yeah
they put this big ass [ __ ] oval of
watermelon I'm like what the [ __ ]
whatever I I was like looking for mine I
liked I tried to look for like Square
images
I've never seen of Kane or well I'll
explain what they're all in hunting so
let's go which way are we gonna how do
you guys want to do it uh just go
through them all I mean okay so actually
before we get into it I'll just tell
which each show is and then we'll talk
about it yeah please number one Banger
Hannah Montana number two in the the
Middle top yeah yeah sure top right
Arcane middle left better call Soul
middle task master uh middle right
Futurama bottom left come dine with me
bottom middle yeah bottom right is Mad
Men okay yes I was I was wondering see
because I've seen this image through
memes let's let's start with custom
designs you should come really loudly
yeah that triggered a response in me
um I'm assuming you didn't put it on
your list gone yes I didn't I didn't
yeah but there's a yes I did yes I did
okay yes no there are a few things here
that I very much considered putting on
uh I was very close to the funny future
Futurama very very close come down with
me as well I think is pretty much the
only I I made my list and I was like
yeah yeah you can tell I'm white without
looking I was like I felt like I made it
and I was like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
but that's fine I am right I too enjoy
Television right so let me explain come
down with me to those who don't know
it's a British TV show and it's
fantastic I swear this thing is shot in
like a budget like a hundred dollars
yeah um they they add like one every day
I don't like understand how this works
it's like they air so many of these
goddamn episodes how many episodes have
come down with me in the UK is that so
the the whole concept behind this TV
show is you get four strangers yeah who
all are very proud of their cooking and
their house and the idea is is that once
in this in this nice uh is it an hour or
30 minutes uh I think it's about 30
minutes 30 minutes they all go do you
get a Womp
who's everyone
so it's four people competing against
each sometimes five sometimes five okay
but most of the time it's four people
and these four people going to take it
in turns to host a dinner party that's
better than me yeah yeah yeah I guess
and within uh within the spin party they
have to impress the guests as much as
possible not just with the food but with
the experience of their home dining
experience right right uh so sometimes
they put as much effort into like
personalize their home dining experience
as possible and at the end of the day
um each contestant rates how good their
experience was and how good the night
was and how good the night was
atmosphere yeah but obviously right like
you're is everyone's voting for each
other it's kind of a trust system of are
you not going to be a dick yeah give
everyone else a one because you want to
win yeah and so it kind of has a lot of
really fun elements to it a lot of snide
moments but also the best part of the
show is the cringe it's so good because
you get a bunch of just generic office
workers just normal people yeah you tell
them they're a dinner party for random
strangers on camera and it's just it's
fantastic and then they also decided and
this is probably the best part of the
show yeah they decided that they were
gonna make the narrator just a guy who
just takes the piss out of everything
they do classic British is just
completely sarcastic right 24 7. and it
just keeps the show going and it keeps
you uh keeps you invested this to me
come down to me this to me is Peak
British reality TV because like I
imagine like a come dine with me in
America God every time I say come now I
can't I can't
come down with me oh my God like every
if I imagine like can you imagine an
American come down with me it'll be like
it would be like the most over the top
[Music]
it's great there's like there's very
minimal editing it's really strong it's
really stale it's like the the thing
that shines about this is just British
sarcasm and Sass because they never say
that they have a bad experience yeah but
that's what makes it good right right
how would you how would you not insult
the uh the host of this dinner party
while we're while still insulting the
host of this dinner party right it's
[ __ ] fantastic and like most of the
time it's like four very average or
below average Cooks just giving each
other [ __ ] right for not I feel like
I've definitely seen Clips yeah it's
really good and
things what were they like while the
person's cooking I'm pretty sure the
producer's like hey go and Snoop around
their house and look at things and
comment and they just like raid each
other's houses it's so bizarre but it's
really fun and I do oh my God it's just
the the amount of bickering and just
bitchiness involved which is fantastic
and it's just so like surface level yeah
like a concert they don't ever say it
they'll be like well Timothy's quiche
was rather cold so I'm gonna have to
dock five points for that and it's like
what what do you mean like you're making
[ __ ] up like you just made it up or like
someone be like the food was all amazing
and one person would be like actually I
hated it it was not the difference it's
like you're right it was it sucked I I
think there's one clip where someone
actually did properly go off like there
was actually drama and it's one of my
favorite like television clips of all
time she's like like because a guy was
like really really salty that someone
else had won right and by the way oh
I've I know this he stands up right and
he stands up what what yeah by the way
the winner they only get like a hundred
quid or something
it doesn't recover the cost to cook the
[ __ ] food people are playing for
pride and there's there's one clip once
one guy gets so [ __ ] salty that
someone else wins and it's like one of
my favorite moments in TV because he
because he just starts like it's the
most British insults that he just starts
throwing out and he just goes well Phil
three to get the [ __ ] out of my house
you reverse out of this like uh you
reverse you reverse you know you walk
with the grace of a dump truck or
something like that it was so good can
we play the clip me down please you won
Jane enjoy the money but I hope now you
spend it on getting some lessons in
Grace and decorum because you have all
the grace of a reversing dump truck
without any tires on oh my God it's it's
just fantastic and it's just like if to
me it's what reality TV should be right
yeah it's like none of this like ruins
someone's life or just make them [ __ ]
miserable or just sell sex sex sex sex
it's like let's just get people to cook
for each other and just let them do like
just give them the tools to have their
own destruction like just saying hey
bring their food right and just see what
happens and it's fantastic I think
there's like a bazillion episodes yeah
there is 151 episodes
[Music]
1051. 1051 episodes yeah basically you
know you know that TV show that just
always seems to be always on this every
day this is always on in one channel or
another if it's not one like channel
four then it's on one of like the reruns
of like one of the other channels it
doesn't matter I'm surprised it even has
Seasons like it's really good yeah it's
very and this is that which is where
that iconic uh meme comes from where the
guy puts the the uh The Colony
it's so gross it's so like revolting but
it's like it sums up like home cooking I
just do it my way yeah yeah you know
what I mean I don't know
um okay so I obviously I know Futurama
uh Hannah Montana obviously keep sure
you guys talk about I feel like you've
told me about people sick on the British
shows then for now let's just go right
to this let's go to Taskmaster okay so
people should then test match okay yeah
yeah okay okay so Peep Show yeah uh I
will explain it poorly you've explained
it to me before I remember yeah
um so imagine two British people whose
life is just not going the way they
wanted right and instead of like
actually doing anything about it they
just take it out on each other and just
cause the most cringe situations for
everyone around them and themselves so
this isn't like this is like narrative
right like it's fiction or it's fiction
and it's but it's not like reality TV
right it is it is one of the most
intentionally cringe shows in existence
right yeah if you love cringe humor this
is this is the king of it right there's
no show that even comes close to this I
mean I think the first episode opens up
uh with Jeremy who is one of the two
main characters of Jeremy and Mark uh
Mark is played by David Mitchell who is
a fantastic kind of he's really great at
playing these Weasley characters yeah
like he's kind of like weasel looking
characters that are very like and he
plays that amazingly he plays this kind
of timid but very like the sky is way
smarter than he is Michael Sierra like
type or Michael Sierra if what
have to go wrong in Michael's here alive
to be
that bad it's like it's like imagine of
actually somewhat intelligent 40 year
old man who just made all the wrong life
decisions all right and is angry at the
world for it right and so he kind of
thinks that he's owed more than he gets
and so he just takes it out on everyone
else in a very British way right and he
just takes it out on Jeremy but Jeremy
is also just a giant buffoon yeah he's
an idiot right and the first episode
opens up I believe with
um Jeremy meets this girl who's wearing
like a beanie and he's like oh she's so
cute I want to have sex with her and
then I think they get together finds out
she has cancer and then doesn't want to
be with her anymore and tries to kind of
break it off in a really weird way and
it's just so cringe where he's trying to
like he said because he doesn't fully
understand like he knows what cancer is
because he's never met anyone with it
he's just really [ __ ] awful yeah
being able to even remotely understand
how to talk to someone with cancer yeah
so he's just like he's like when did
this come out it's like 2009 okay so I
was going to say this very 2000's human
yeah no no this is like this this is
easily air today
at all this is age like perfectly
because I still watch it to this day
right right me and Sydney still binge
all of the seasons unfortunately one of
the bad things about British televisions
unlike Americans keeping Seasons yeah
yeah every like there's like seven
seasons of Peep Show but like every
season has six episodes that's and
that's six half an hour episodes as well
but like this is what I really love
about sunbridge TV shows it really feels
like it earns the six episodes 30
minutes each where it's like there is
not a single beat Mist in this show yeah
like there is no episode that sucks yeah
there's no episode that isn't funny and
there's no episode where there isn't
like five moments that isn't gonna make
you laugh out loud yeah right right just
like I sometimes it's just every almost
every episode I think in Peep Show is an
absolute Banger there are some lines
that are just like stuck with me for
like my entire life there's okay there's
a there's a completely unrelated plot
line I feel like this sums it up so well
yeah uh there's a there's a there's an
episode where Jeremy is one of the
characters uh Works in a gym and Mark is
going to this gym and doesn't really
want to go to it but it's kind of being
forced to and Jeremy for some why does
Jeremy want to not go to the gym anymore
he does why does he not want to work
there I can't remember why
um
I remember what he does I remember oh I
think he joined it to get with a girl or
something like that yeah so he joins the
gym to get with this attractive uh other
worker there yeah and meanwhile Mark
doesn't want to go to the gym anymore
right so he makes up this elaborate
excuse that one of the masseuses touched
him yeah and it's like it's this whole
awkward ordeal where he has to go to the
office to the manager yeah and awkwardly
explain that he was touched while the
guy is there the masseuse right it's
just this stumbling horrible
cringe-inducing thing and and he and he
touched me and the guy said what the
[ __ ] I didn't touch you and then to get
fired because Jeremy doesn't want to
work there anymore he like shits in the
pool and then tries to blame somebody
else it's this whole like it's just it
goes from zero to a hundred every single
episode where everything just
accumulates and and builds and it's just
fantastic it's so good yeah it's it's
cringe humor at its best it's British
humor at its best
um if you want to feel like you're
British for some reason why I don't know
what you would watch this TV show tell
them to tell the British person you've
watched this show they'll love you
exactly I mean Sydney [ __ ] loves this
show that's you know and that's how I
knew that she could understand British
humor if you can get Peep Show because I
show Peep Show to my mum and dad they're
like why why is this it's too much for
my parents as well yeah it's too much
cringe it's a lot yeah there is not a
single episode where you won't be
uncomfortable yeah the way the best way
I can describe it is like just imagine
two [ __ ] [ __ ] and try not to be
[ __ ] but in the end of the day
they're just they're just trying to get
on with life but they somehow find
themselves in the worst [ __ ]
situations right now it's so good and
like it's not just even these two
characters there's so many like
if you've lived in England you've like
recognized who these people are because
there's like some you know you know
somebody sometimes you have a show that
you it's a bit it's a bit too close to
home sometimes yeah because there are
some characters that you kind of
recognize as a person that you've met in
your life before in the UK yeah
um like one of one character that stands
out to me is like super hands oh my God
I think I think Super hands who's just
that guy who just brings drugs to
everything right and and he's just like
he's just lost control of his life right
right why is he called Superhead no one
knows no one knows this guy's just
insane and like there's you know it's
also shot really interestingly it's all
POV yeah I think that's why it's called
Peep Show yeah yeah because yeah and
they shoot the scenes multiple times but
like so the camera keeps swapping
between the povs in the scenes so it's
never a uh an angle of like okay his
over the shoulder it's like it's always
POV oh which makes for some really good
moments because a lot of the times
really really awkward moments hit so
hard because the person who sees you
that the awkward thing happened looks
directly at the camera yeah and it's
looking at it like you did it yeah yeah
it's really good it's so good it's
really interesting and it's just amazing
again it's it's I know the TV show is
kind of shot like this to my knowledge
and it just works yeah oh that's
interesting yeah watch Peep Show it's
amazing I know I know you guys like rave
on about it yeah and the POV thing also
makes it feel very uncomfortable because
you're often in the face right there's a
lot and it feels like you're there you
kind of feel like okay this is cool
Gamers Gamers let me tell you about
gamersups I will literally die if I
don't drink Gamer sucks sugar isn't good
for you but gamer Subs is Gamers if you
need a clean energy drink with no
crashes no sugar and tastes amazing you
should be drinking some game of Subs
Gamers if you don't need energy but you
just want to replace all that sugary
crap we have the caffeine free version
as
you know that gamersups also doesn't
miss with flavors such the classics
known as and I'm reading this correctly
Kitty milk or guacamole game of thought
and did you know that even though it's
not available anymore you can drink out
of our trash taste waifu cups as well
isn't that right Joey get that trash out
of here because my real waifu has just
released her own cup it goes on sale on
November 28th so guys come on please
support my wife guys come on she needs
it she needs it you better use coupon
code trash taste when doing that okay or
I will die
so get yourself this new and awesome
gamer waifu cup at gamestops.gg trash
taste and use our coupon code trash test
add checking get it or I will come to
your house and kill you
bye back to the episode yeah and then
obviously Taskmaster yeah which I think
is it's okay so Taskmaster let me
explain it before I get into it but I
think this shows is is blowing up and
it's gonna blow up a [ __ ] ton in the US
as well more I know a lot of people have
recently coming up to him from the US
like have you heard a single task master
I'm like yeah yes it's very old in the
UK right uh it's I don't even know how
you explain this uh you get a bunch of
comedians together yeah I actually
wanted to do a task master for after
dark yeah we definitely want to do this
at something yeah the format is just
gold yes okay so so basically such good
it's kind of like a game show but not
really and now that you've put
Taskmaster on I'm like [ __ ] I have so
many shows I should have put on my list
that I completely forgot there was this
genre so that that happens a lot yeah I
wanted to put up a panel or slash kind
of thingy type kind of yeah so I think
this is like a very British genre of TV
show which is why I completely forgot
about it where it's kind of like this
British panel slash game right but the
get but the uh the uh but what you don't
try to do in this game show is Win
basically they just try to be as
entertaining as possible right so with
task master it's basically like a game
show where you take a bunch of comedians
on and then you give them the same task
right it could be anything right could
range from getting a marble out of a
bottle that's been sealed and like full
of jelly or some [ __ ] right there's some
really obscure like things that you're
like why would you do this like yeah you
know there'll be like 30 shocks and be
like find the orange yeah a sock but all
of them will have something different
and you're allowed to like sniff three
or touch two right yeah so so they give
stuff yeah so they're given like a very
they're given a very Ambiguously worded
task right Sometimes some tasks are more
ambiguous than others but it's up to the
contestant to figure out what is the
best way to do this task right and so
there's always like a life hack to
solving it yeah yeah there's there's not
always a life so it'll be just a house
and you can do anything in the house
with the challenge so like for one
challenge it'll be like they'll be in a
room and they'll be like hide three
eggplants in the room okay whoever hides
their eggplants the longest from the guy
searching wins yeah all right so it's
like you know some some contestants hide
the eggplant others Smash Up the
eggplant and try to like squish it into
something yeah yeah you know and some
people start eating whole eggplants yeah
it's like there's the rules are always
set so ambiguous where any
interpretation is correct and it's up to
the Taskmaster to decide if somebody
deserves the point based on yeah you
know because maybe somebody did
something it's a little a little too
cheeky in the Taskmaster Yeah by Greg
Davis who's amazing we'll be like no I
don't like that yeah that's why it's
like perfect for trash days because we
can't follow the rules oh [ __ ] yes so
the rules are ambiguous and then you
never follow them and then the guy in
charge just changed his mind yeah yeah
yeah so so that's that's that's the
point right I'm sure a lot of people be
like I can't believe he lost this task
because he didn't follow the rules
correctly well that's not really the
point of task master the point of task
master is just to see the funny ways
that different people can get creative
different people approach the same time
right right oh that sounds fun yeah yeah
and and you can go as out of the box as
you want the only important thing is you
gotta it's kind of like you kind of
gotta like
try to not to take the piss but also
take the piss as well right so I
remember what like one one task I
remember recently was there was this
switch in this room and the task was
figure out what this switch does right
yeah and so what happens is like nine
people out of ten they start they start
flipping on the switch running out
looking at every light in the house
looking at every Appliance in the house
seeing if anything's changed run back in
and like flip the switch off and then
they they repeat this process right
until they finally figure out that the
switch rotates a statue or something
that's that's what that's what the
switch did yeah one guy just cut the
power to the switch right and was just
like well switch does nothing
because it has no power
oh wow so that's that's the kind of like
thinking outside the box because it
didn't necessarily because he's
technically right yeah in that this
twitch does nothing in that moment
because he's seriously not breaking the
rules because there's no rules right
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's that's very
loose rules yeah that's very very loose
one of the best things is is that it's
completely available on YouTube for free
yep you can watch all of it nearly all
of it on YouTube for free yeah uh which
is amazing because the clips they have
Eclipse Channel which is amazing but you
can just watch the straight up the whole
episodes oh cool and the best part is is
that it's it's structured in a way where
every episode has its own self-contained
thing right uh in like a greater season
so it'll be the same comedians for the
whole season and the points will rack up
but you could come into any episode and
enjoy an episode like there is nothing
that requires you to watch the previous
episode right right if you want to and
you'll get more out of it you can go one
two three four up until the end then you
can see who the winner is yeah yeah so
it's Seasons they have like five
Comedians and they change kind of it
makes it a bit more consistent and makes
it have a lot more re-watchability and
more reasons to tune in every week it's
really good really really good yeah it's
going to blow up in the year I highly
recommend it we'll probably do do a task
Market I think a lot I know it's already
popular nice because they made a US
version that sucked as they always do of
course but I think a lot more YouTubers
and stuff will probably start doing some
stuff like that oh yeah it's going to
happen I don't think so it's good
Taskmaster is [ __ ] amazing that's all
my British TV shows that I recommend uh
what is mind Hunter did any of you know
what mindhunter is no no mind Hunter is
so good so mine hunter unfortunately uh
at least it's just my knowledge is not
going to continue I think you can Google
this
um it had two seasons and then for some
reason Netflix or I think some creative
staff involved didn't agree on some
stuff maybe Kai can fact check for me uh
but it's basically about it's a really
good Netflix like drama but kind of
loosely based on real events of
why the the FBI decided to start
figuring out what psychopaths are
is this a drama or like a drama but kind
of loosely based on real events very
Loosely because you know they they were
a lot of the time you know way back in
America people were killing people with
similarly no motive and nobody can
understand why certain groups of these
people were very very organized would
didn't seem to care about the killings
would kill like 10 people and then some
people in the FBI are like huh I think
we should study these people who have
clearly very intelligent very good at
their crimes and who clearly are not
like the other criminals yeah right
yeah right well you know it's basically
like this is where it's a story about
how basically psychopath profiling
started every true Chrome fan
but dude it's so good like the the
acting the shots the cinematography the
pacing is amazing do we have info
it's on indefinitely which basically
means it's done yeah and it's it sucks
so it is they go um in the first season
they basically you spend a lot of the
seasons with this this FBI guy who's
really dedicated to figuring out this
because he really believes that if if
they can figure out what makes these
Psychopaths tick and why they're doing
this that it can help them profile in
future and figure out how to stop this
happening yeah again this is all based
on like Loosely based on true events and
whatnot so the interview a very famous
serial killer uh over across the first
season called Ed camper who is like uh
oh yes I know very very famous yeah and
the actor in the series who portrays him
is insane he's so good I think I've seen
the clips of that the guy who like
killed his mother and killed his family
and then went on to kill and he killed
so many people and the only reason they
caught him is because he got bored and
turned himself in yeah right and he was
really well spoken didn't like you know
I've seen like interviews of the real
age really creepy guy really creepy
because he would just be like he would
be willing to admit anything and talk
about it in full and so a lot of the
first season is just them talking to him
going back and forth trying to convince
the higher-ups this is worth doing going
back to Ed talking to him the main
character getting a little bit too
invested in talking to this serial
killer right and it's just really good
and it's it's just such a good human
drama whilst also kind of showcasing
like a really fascinating part of FBI
kind of history and this kind of how
they came up to start even doing this
yeah right every True Crime fan yeah and
then the second season I think they have
some Charles Manson stuff another famous
serial killer again it's all really
really interesting if you want a really
good kind of crime uh detective not to
say that like like you know a really
unnerving drama okay is this did this
Series start off with some guy blowing
off his head with a shotgun or something
you know I watched this when it came out
yeah and I remember that it's just been
one of those shows where I always check
every like month I'm like yeah is
anything happening because I really it
was getting so good yeah it's the dad
that went together
but even because because the two seasons
are so good I still feel comfortable
recommending it being like this is such
still worth watching yeah it's so good
because because I remember Sydney was
like oh I want to watch a show it's on
Netflix and stuff like that and I'm like
what is it about and she was like serial
killers I'm like great okay all right
you're from Wisconsin I get it okay I
remember just like walking in the room
seeing someone blow the head off of the
shotgun I can't I've had a massive
spoiler no problem it's like opening
scene
um and then I just walked out I was like
the guy with the thing around his neck
and blew up or a shotgun definitely
shotgun okay that's the other evil but
it was like a drama it wasn't like a
documentary I've seen it I've seen Evil
Geniuses that's that's good super
Geniuses game horrifying yeah I mean
mindhunter is amazing if you want just a
great drama you want to be fascinated
enthralled you've got to watch it it's
on Netflix it's a shame that we're not
gonna get a season three please bring
back season three yeah so Hannah Montana
all right let's talk about it yeah I
mean again look you've talked about you
had a child a crush on Hannah Montana
but like sell me on the show because
I've seen oh no it's not good but that's
the thing I've seen bits and pieces of
the show it's not good at all I think I
think though in a week is this your
guilty pleasure no
um I feel like this has a lot more uh
impact on me than I'd care to admit it
does I hate to be like but you know when
you're a child you're impressionable you
know at the end of the day I'm not
afraid to admit that Hannah Montana
changed my life then were you how how
did uh the the change that mileage
affect you what's Hannah Montana about
I've not seen a single episode right so
there's it's a great question go on
fantastic question so there's Hannah
who's from Hannah Montana yeah the stage
name is Hannah Montana it's this girl uh
I can't remember why she wants to be on
stage I'm sure just because her dad
because her dad is uh Billy Ray Cyrus
who's in like actual musician right um
I'm sure that I'm sure that helped get
the show Achy Breaky Heart yeah yeah
literally oh so it's about her who she's
trying to get in school but she doesn't
want people in school to know that she's
a pop star so she lives this dual life
where it's it's just Hannah she's living
the best yeah so that's the way the Best
of Both Worlds come from so she's trying
to balance the nobody nobody can know
I'm Hannah Montana yeah but also I got
to go to school but also I do these hit
performances yeah I don't know what her
real name is and her name in the show is
uh Hannah Smith is it really I don't
know I think it's only sometimes but I
don't know it's just fun and I think I'm
in a weird way
um I think like the whole Hannah Montana
and the Disney and all that kind of got
me into like American culture a lot more
right got me into the path of kind of
liking the idea of maybe performing yeah
because before that I had I had no no
desire in my bone to to perform or get
on a stage so basically you watched
Hannah Montana and you went I want the
best I I did want The Best of Both
Worlds and now as a social media person
I was like how about just one world and
I'll make that the best one you combined
the world think further Hannah go
further Beyond yeah so I I don't know in
a weird way the Disney channel has this
weird kind of intoxicating effect on
kids that is like yeah you want to be a
little [ __ ] entertaining little [ __ ]
yeah
in a weird way I think it kind of does
it does it's just basically the you know
the the show for theater kids
everyone on the Disney show is like a
theater and I hate to admit it because I
think the show sucks in a weird way uh
but it was fun at the time and I did I
was obsessed with it again it just got
me into it and at a time where nobody uh
you know because I find in school
if you're not a theater kid yeah you are
never allowed to be a theater kid yeah
you can never join you know what I mean
there is a cut-off period if you are not
in the theater kid period by like age
eight you are not allowed in the theater
the thing the thing is you have to be
born and raised they are a ruthless
Bunch yeah where they lied to a bed at
night you can join the football team if
you get better you cannot become a
theater kid no no and that and that [ __ ]
stays with you oh yeah yeah like a kid
always a thing have you ever meet
someone and then they were like yeah I
was a theater kid I'm like I [ __ ]
knew it I knew it I can sense it from
the aura you know you feel the pressure
for sure
it stays with you I swear they never
drop it but again like in school I I a
part of me I had that tiny little
inkling I was like I'd love to try this
yeah but even at 10 I'm like the
window's gone because like you're like
yeah because the teachers wouldn't
wouldn't pick you yeah because they
would never give you the opportunity to
do anything because they were like well
we already know we like these kids yeah
we know who can these are the kids that
act yeah you're not the kid that acts
you're the kids at times the audition
and then we make the kids at act feel
good because we can pick them you know
it's like and and this is a thing that I
felt in a weird way I hate Disney with a
burning passion I think they're a tower
company uh but
predict where credit's due a little bit
of it kind of brought out that that I
was like [ __ ] you know I kind of wanna
but I didn't know how how do you how do
you get into it and that's kind of like
what kind of maybe planted the seed to
then when I found anime that made me
think actually I want a voice act did
you did you ever watch like High School
Musical yeah I didn't really want to
sing right something about acting kind
of spoke to me uh but it doesn't handle
a Tennessee yeah she sings but it was
kind of the acting part of it a lot of
these kid actors I thought they were
amazing yeah yeah props to the kid
actors I don't know how the [ __ ] they
did that yeah I can't act now bro um you
know and I think that planted the seeds
to make me want to pursue something and
then discovered voice acting and that
was like stars aligned right so that
planted the seeds to me but also you
know I a lot of people like they can't
get into theater and I I like that
there's ways or kind of motivations
pushing us to do it because you know
like people like [ __ ] Gerard Butler
right or uh who we'll talk about later
uh uh [ __ ] uh uh Dawn and
um mad man what's his [ __ ] name in
real life Jon Hamm Jon Hamm you know
those two are both School teachers yeah
just got into acting at like age 40. and
I love that [ __ ] I want more of that
yeah yeah I hate it when it's like if
you didn't act from age 10 get the [ __ ]
out of the industry you're a joke it's
like I hate that [ __ ] I think acting
should be like if you want to try it Go
the [ __ ] ahead if you don't if nothing
comes of it who cares yeah I think
having a way to express yourself and
having a way to perform is so uh just
fulfilling and satisfying I don't know
why [ __ ] Hannah Montana put that in
my brain but thank you Hannah Montana
thank you Miley expression Express
Yourself guys yeah all right uh then
let's talk about Mad Men I guess all
right I know the name of this show never
seen a single episode yeah
it's like advertising right this is like
the Chad show before Chad shows exists
like Jon Hamm plays like a giga chat I
love John Hammond but like it's great
because
in the show it starts out as like yeah
John uh I think it's all day of Don Don
the show he you know he's this kind of
he knows everything he's smart he's
killing it but as the show goes on they
they slowly introduce flaws to him and
humanize him
um and in a way that feels great and and
it's about it deals with a lot of the
topics at the time like this is like
1950s it deals with a lot of sexism it
deals with a lot of misogyny uh it deals
with other cultures not being uh
recognized at the time and how that
interacts Mad Men is about John and and
the Ad Agency they make ads for people
okay so a lot of the time the show is
just how do we make this happen
newspapers and billboards and stuff like
that big Brands they're like the premium
a grade yeah marketing company in New
York Manhattan okay well this this is
when like our agencies start to become
like a real world oh yeah oh yeah they
started realizing oh if you advertise
correctly you could make like a [ __ ] ton
of money oh yeah right yeah so you know
a lot of the drama comes from okay we're
interacting with this client they have
these needs and how that character
interacts and it's a great way of
introducing characters for a few
episodes that have a big impact on the
main cast yeah and then how that kind of
plays out in their life yeah and there's
a great scene that I feel like after
you've lived in Japan you're like yes I
understand this they have like there's a
scene where they like have a [ __ ] uh
they maybe like Toyota or something and
one of the Japanese car brands right and
they made like the Ad Agency compete
against another Ad Agency to make the
best ad and they wouldn't like geek
shows I will not make an ad to compete
you will buy my services or you are not
welcome and they go out and it was just
like this whole thing of I will not
dance for you I was like I feel that so
much now this happens so much in Japan
we have to do [ __ ]
wow no no but it's great it's a great
show if you want what what makes it good
what makes it good characters I think uh
like one like like better call song
which I'll talk about like really good
characters really good writing yeah you
know it's a slow burn nothing crazy
happens nothing explosive happens every
every episode it's just if you like
people talking you like good dialogue
you like development I like good dialo
it's it's just a great show and it's
it's very slow to start with I think
that's the problem with that a lot of
people don't get into it because it
feels like all right when's something
gonna happen but they're just laying the
foundation I really love Mad Men because
because like I've always found the
advertising world just uh interesting to
begin with I feel like I explained it
poorly by the way yeah it's it's like
especially seeing like the evolution of
the advertising world like you look at
like the old days and like the 60s or
something and like an advertisement
would literally be here's my product
here's what it does let me list off all
the benefits of using this products and
then yeah like I think like somewhere
along the line I'm not sure if it was
like likes must be TV all right you know
it was you know this was this was on TV
but yeah but somewhere along the line I
think like the most the biggest example
I can give off is like I can think of is
like the cigarette industry where Marvel
started like they they stopped marketing
their products and they started like
marketing a feeling a lifestyle yeah
yeah yeah instead of just being like hey
here are cigarettes they're gonna
[ __ ] kill you oh by the way you know
buy our product they're they're like
this is the American way yeah it's like
it's like Peak 1950s America where
they're figuring that stuff out wasn't
it like uh was it like Coca-Cola that
were like one of the first ones to do it
might have been really just like it's
this is the feeling that you get yeah
this is what it's like it's like the how
it feels to chew five guns it's like
that it's like that [ __ ] you know but
it's great it's a long one it's got like
nine Seasons okay right but you slowly
watched Don's life uh change quite a lot
but it's good it's good though it's it's
worth it I got into it and I I couldn't
stop like it was it was enthralling all
right yeah okay uh we also have future
drama I mean need I say much about
future yeah we were all this I guess we
were all this close to putting Futurama
on it's like I don't know it's like how
do you make like it's it's like macaroni
inside I'm gonna make a show that's
funnier than Simpsons has a storyline
has characters that you love more and
just hits every note I feel as well the
humor is a little more geared towards
like the older generation I think oh
yeah because like because you know
Simpsons has a lot of Chloe Simpsons is
very good early symptoms yeah but like
around like comparing it to The Simpsons
during the time that Futurama was airing
like alongside I definitely felt like
they cared way more about Futurama yeah
yeah it's kind of like a throwback to
more than old school Simpsons type of
[ __ ] right yeah yeah I mean one thing
I've always loved about Futurama is that
they actually gave a [ __ ] about the
Sci-Fi setting yeah in the world yeah it
wasn't just like a haha here wacky
setting haha they're like there are so
many episodes in Futurama that they
really delved into this like really like
Niche scientific concept or something
like that it was basically kind of like
Peak Rick and Morty before Rick and
Morty
Rick and Morty could walk
I want to have any Rick and Morty fans
I'm gonna piss off with that yeah I mean
it's especially like when they started
delving into more of the story aspect oh
yeah drama holy [ __ ] oh some of the
latest some of the later episodes made
me cry yeah like [ __ ] Fry's dog is
gonna [ __ ] stick with I I mentioned
that you know and everyone everyone has
the exact same reaction just like really
funny jokes as well like using the
Sci-Fi setting to like a huge Advantage
yeah like I just like one of the First
episodes right it's like Bender goes in
the suicide Booth right yeah tries to
and tries to con it and I feel like that
tells you literally everything you need
to know about Bender oh yeah the guy
doesn't want to pay even for his own
suicide we'll try and con it and then
gives up immediately like it's like they
just it's such good writing and and you
can tell that everyone on the team cared
so much about making the show as funny
as possible yeah and I just love it so
much and I love the episode where Fry
drinks like 100 coffees one of my
favorite ones
love that episode so much so that's such
a good [ __ ] everyone
so much yeah what I love about Futurama
is just the cast as well it's just it's
it's rare that you see such a perfectly
balanced cast like like Eve I think it's
like even better than the Simpsons oh
yeah in terms of balance the side
characters definitely shine in that shot
and even like even like the every now
and then characters that you see in like
just some of the concepts that you see
like you know obviously because like you
know because it's Futurama and like Matt
Rainey show it's like okay we'll throw
in maybe like a couple of like celebrity
naughties and stuff like that but the
fact that these like celebrity cameos
make their way into few trauma as just
the head yeah in a glass it's like
that's that's like immediately way more
funnier than just like here's the
character that you all know and love
that just comes into the frame it's like
yeah it's a little more interesting uh
and then and then I guess the fine uh
two final ones okay sure Arcane yeah I
mean Jerry come on all right so Arcane
is is fantastic there's like 70 clips of
you guys talking about okay I just think
that Arcane should be watched this is
your weekly reminder to watch our can if
you haven't yeah I am I am frothing at
the thought of getting a season two all
right Julie know that you want to talk
about Better Call Saul and I just think
they've released the behind the scenes
recently that was fantastic yeah they
really just showed how much love and
care went into it yeah
I agree yeah what what you said Connor
yeah what do you say I don't know what
more I can say about Arcane it's a show
that hits the ground running it's good
save me it's uh it's uh Joey's favorite
show I love it all right Hunter Hunter
and I came my top two favorites so I
figured that God would would not put
breaking bad because maybe we're going
to talk about it anyway I don't know if
maybe God did for Breaking Bad I figured
we're going to talk about breaking bad
okay Universe spoiler spoiler I didn't
actually put broken back I've never even
seen it but I figured we would want to
talk about it in some capacity okay
because I mean it's like it's breaking
[ __ ] mad yeah
my favorite are you putting breaking
battle are you putting benefits the
universe is the universe the universe
yeah I think like what is that you I
would put both of them on here but I
feel like what is that Universal coin
okay the metaverse the Vince Gilligan
Universe I don't know like the the whole
world of Breaking Bad and better call
soul is fantastic and honestly I mean
the only reason I put medical Souls
because it just finished recently and it
was it was insane it's so good like one
of the best TV shows I've ever watched
like flat out just I mean I've been
watching the show weekly well not weekly
like since it aired weekly uh since I
was in university right because I was
watching Breaking Bad when that was
airing weekly when I was like 15. and I
just think that there's something about
it that I mean it clearly captivates
everyone online as well yeah people are
in love with this world and the show and
I think it's just because of how just
careful and how meticulous all the
character writing is yeah and how you
know there's a lot of twists and turns
in Breaking Bad and medical soul but it
doesn't feel feel like it's done for any
particular shock value it's like you
know if a character dies it is a big big
deal and it's dealt with really severely
in the show and a character's death has
such Rippling effects on everyone in the
cast and it bothers them and it changes
how they view things and I I can't do it
justice I mean Breaking Bad and medical
assault you probably know all about it
it is just amazing and I hate being that
normally guys like watch Breaking Bad
it's a good TV show but it just is it's
literally it just is an amazing show
yeah I mean I don't know if I don't know
if this is going to be a hot take or not
but like yeah I've seen breaking bads I
think it's an amazing show I have zero
emotional attachment to it which is why
I didn't put it on my list right yeah it
like I think Breaking Bad epitomizes
everything that I guess does not
interest me about TV American TV shows
what what are you wearing where it's
just it's what do you mean okay
my perception of Breaking Bad is every
reason why I am an anime fan if that
makes sense okay where I think Breaking
Bad isn't like I look at it as a Critic
right I think it's an amazing show it's
got so many moving pieces there's so
much care and attention that's been put
into the writing and the themes and how
how the uh how the developments of the
show evolve and everything like that but
it's it's it's polished it's it's to me
it's like it's it's a show that's like
polished to a point
that's it's how I don't know how to say
it it's polished to a point where
it just doesn't interest me is that
weird is that weird bro I never even
gave it a chance why would you not want
to see the Pinnacle in like TV
storytelling
uh I think one one okay one big thing
again uh is that it's so grounded in
reality right the part of the reason why
so many people are attached to so many
of these characters because they they
feel like like such well don't want your
characters to feel real
he's an isakai fan yeah but like I think
I think it is an extremely tall order to
make characters that feel real and and
somehow Breaking Bad in medical Soul are
Masters at making you care about these
characters oh yeah who are so well
written and unbelievable yeah yeah they
are incredibly well written too like I
saw a fault it's so strange I've never
heard anyone have that complaint yeah I
know I mean I don't even know if it's a
complaint right I'm complaining that the
show is too good we've studied regards
brain yeah yeah I mean I mean here's a
some sometimes you love sometimes I like
a bit of rawness in the expression
sometimes I like a bit of unpolished you
know unpolishness you know sometimes I
like it when something is just is not
like this well refined
it's too clean this is such a bizarre
argument this is going to build on one
of the shows that I'm going that I've
put on my okay which is okay this is
half of a hot tick right okay I like I
think Breaking Bad is an amazing show
but I I have zero attachment to Breaking
Bad I hear this if you didn't have zero
attachment to it but I could understand
that I just think I I loved it a lot
maybe it's because I you know when I
first watched it I was like 16. yeah
I've rewatched it since and I still love
it I just think it's just amazing like
it just does everything so goddamn well
yeah yeah exactly well I guess why it's
like [ __ ] number two on IMDb yeah I
mean do you think that you do you think
medical saw is better than Breaking Bad
now that it's over
that's tough
um I think if you had to pick one of the
two
I think Breaking Bad offers a more
complete package of
hitting every kind of emotion soul is a
very very slow burn yes that really
believes that in its storytelling and
its characters to to tell an amazing
story yes it knows that the characters
of in the universe are so strong that
they can really slow it down yeah and
and you know because the first two
seasons it's a very very slow burden not
that much happens and it's like for two
seasons it's very slow it's all just
setting the stage building up these
characters showing you why they're going
to be why they are and it's like it's so
rare to see a prequel that almost
improves on what the main thing did and
kind of offers even more reason to go
back and watch the first of the original
like
you know the Jimmy's character of Saul
in Breaking Bad is is very funny very
funny loyal man but just make medical
Soul turns him into this amazing
grounded character where you can
understand why he went down the paths he
went down yeah just it's just a great
drama it's it but it's slow it's very
slow yeah I think that's why Breaking
Bad might just Edge it out for me right
Breaking Bad just hits the ground
running right yeah probably because he
had to do a pilot and whereas the
medical Soul could had the had the brand
had more Wiggles Yeah well yeah I mean
the reason I think a lot of people
wouldn't watch Better Call Saul or
wouldn't have got past the first season
if they didn't know it's part of
Breaking Bad because it is just it it
just trusts that you want to see the
payoff right yeah I I think I've got a
perfect analogy of why I
I'm not personally attached to Breaking
Bad
so Breaking Bad is like if you built an
AI computer
and you programmed it to write the
perfect TV show that would be Breaking
Bad okay you know like it feels like it
is the perfect TV show with with correct
Spanish in it apparently the Spanish is
Dreadful I don't know
okay apparently the Spanish is like
unwatchable Spanish people I'm so sorry
especially but at least a medical Soul
they have an actual uh Spanish person uh
playing a character and he's really
[ __ ] good yeah no Gustavo is not even
remotely Spanish oh and apparently his
Spanish is Dreadful oh really yeah
apparently it's [ __ ] unbearable uh
because he's supposed to be playing a
Chilean dude yeah but he's uh from like
Denmark or something and has African
descent oh so there's no Spanish ties
remotely
um so people are like bro his Hispanic
should yeah yeah that's that's I think
that's that's what I mean it's like it
feels like the perfect TV show but it
feels so good that it feels like it was
written by a computer and why would you
not want it so you say so what you're
basically saying is that like some flaws
in the show are good because the guys
actually rotted your brain I mean it has
okay I'm not gonna lie but like
sometimes okay even watch like sometimes
one of my favorite things is kind of
like feeling a connection between the
person who made this particular thing or
this particular piece of fiction
um I like feeling like there is I
understand what they're trying to
portray or Express you know with
Breaking Bad I Feel Complete coldness
because I feel it's just amazing it's
perfectly written but I don't know what
you know so there's nothing wrong with
like the like a show being like
inherently perfect in its writing or
like incredibly good in its writing yeah
like you need some kind of thing that
gives you a connection between you as a
viewer and the person who made it trying
to express themselves through the work I
mean I mean that's why Evangeline was
like I was about to say this
is like one of my favorite anime of all
time you know it doesn't doesn't
necessarily have to make sense I wonder
if that's just a posted my person thing
because I feel like I get it oh it's
definitely a person I I feel like I
understand the messages they're trying
to put out and yeah they're trying to
portray yeah I feel the same thing with
music it's like sometimes you just want
to listen to a good song and not give a
[ __ ] about who it's made by yeah
sometimes you want to be like well I
need to care about the song Because I
want to care about this person yeah who
made it yeah I know Chris loves medical
Souls that's a good taste sheep all
right who's next who is next then
go for this person
Jerry oh it's me okay we're going in
order yeah all right time for some weird
[ __ ] now this episode is sponsored by
boxing boxer is the monthly subscription
Japanese snack box that delivers
authentic Japanese snacks straight to
your door they work with family
businesses all over Japan to send you a
new theme of goodies every single month
come on what do you got there well God
I'm glad you asked this is the seasons
of Japan
this is basically the MVP the highlights
of all the Japanese seasons and flavors
in one box and luckily for you guys when
you have your first order of box suit
this is the first box you'll receive
following that the boxes you will
receive will be the ones that match the
themes of every single month I gotta say
each box is completely packed and it
also comes with the booklet that teaches
you all about the snacks unique flavors
and where they come from what are some
of the unique flavors we have today
gentlemen well I found this uh kumamon
black sesame rice these are these are
actually really mascot everywhere what
do you have there I have here a tsuki
Samu anpan chocolates I've never tried
this boy open Joey how does that one
taste give it a taste it looks like a
coaster does it tastes like a coaster or
is it full of flavors it tastes
delicious that looks good yeah that
actually does look good oh [ __ ] that is
delicious dog damn I might have to
reorder this one just for this one snack
honestly just give me this one snack
boxy please oh God I bet you're enjoying
that but if you give box you as a
present you get to give someone you love
a fun and unique food experience and
support our channels at the same time
it's a win-win and don't forget to click
the link in the description and use our
coupon code trashtaste 15 to get 15 off
your very first box you order I'm
helping back to the episode oh hell yeah
okay so what is this so yeah some of
these are a very Australian I I'm
praying to God if there is a single
person watching this episode right now
who looks at all nine of these and goes
like yeah I like these you just name
what they all are very quickly okay so
we got Simpsons specs and specs Adams
Family MythBusters edit native fat Pizza
Russell quotes all Aussie adventures and
Arthur okay
literally
because half of these are from your
[ __ ] childhood yes of course they are
yeah I don't watch TV series Simpsons
why Simpsons ever say like you just
mentioned okay so I was really debating
at first I put in Futurama but then the
more I thought about it I have more of a
childhood connection with the Simpsons
okay
um even though Futurama came out what
year did it come out like uh no not too
long ago too long after I was like
mid-2000s I think or late 2000s okay
look it up but I feel Simpsons was that
like one cartoon that has always been
around and I have like fond childhood
memories of watching Simpsons with my
sister more than Futurama so like the
the only like I guess uh childhood
memory I have of me watching Simpsons
was before uh my my dad inevitably threw
it out he had this like old CRT TV right
and he was gonna throw it out and I was
like no no father I want it if it
doesn't still work and he's like yeah if
you like get the antenna thing on it and
you extend the [ __ ] yeah then it
still works and I'm like okay can I put
it in my room and so there would be
nights where like my dad would be
watching some kind of [ __ ] TV show I
didn't give a [ __ ] about and my sister
and I would go into my room and we would
take turns holding the antenna on the TV
to get good reception enough to watch
reruns of The Simpsons and so every and
because it was play it played on channel
10 there were like ad breaks every like
you know 10-15 minutes so every time an
ad break came on we'll be like all right
your turn to hold the antenna and I
would just have like fond childhood
memories of that and like that would
happen after Futurama came out because
in Australia it would be a rerun of The
Simpsons and then immediately after it
would be an episode of Futurama right
right
um so it would it would kind of be like
a Simpsons Futurama combo for me but I
still remember more and vividly remember
more characters and jokes and stuff like
that from The Simpsons I consumed a lot
more Simpsons than Futurama
there was way more of it yeah and I
thought because it like I remember I
grew up with The Simpsons oh yeah yeah
The Simpsons was The Simpsons existed
since I was born yeah it's like a game
every year yeah yeah exactly clear it
came out it came out every day but then
I remember when Futurama first started
airing it was like a new thing yeah so
Simpsons has just like always been there
when did you try and come out 1999 1999
oh okay yeah what what is your do you
have a favorite Simpsons episode that
comes to mind
Peak Simpsons for me is the 24 short
stories about Springfield do you know
that one which one's what's the plot of
that one again it's basically just like
they it's it's basically just like a
[ __ ] Quentin Tarantino escalate just
short stories about different characters
in Springfield that all coincide with
one another and there's a lot of like
movie parodies and [ __ ] like that they
parody like Pulp Fiction multiple times
and like just like classic movies and
stuff but with Simpsons characters yeah
um and it's just a really and also like
uh we used to have like DVDs of like the
Treehouse of Horrors I love those are
like classes
like like The Shining Parody episode of
The Simpsons is like that's Peak I love
the uh who shot Mr Burns who shot Mr
Burns and also like the the robot house
of death and stuff like that oh my God
yeah well it's like this they like
Implement like an AI like house and it's
voiced by all the characters who played
James Bond yeah oh yeah it's like it's
voiced by Pierce Brosnan I think who
shot Mr Burns was how I discovered what
Cliffhangers were yeah right like
honestly I remember like genuinely good
stories yeah I remember as a kid I was
watching who the who shot Mr Burns part
one and then it ends right I'm like what
do you mean it's ending what where is
part two
what do you mean I have to wait I'm like
five or something right yeah but like it
the writing was so good that you know
you got a [ __ ] child invest yeah and
I and I think as well like I had a
really good because like obviously
Simpsons started way before any of us
were born yeah and so like a lot of the
The Simpsons that we saw on that shitty
CR TV were reruns of the older Seasons
which anyone who's watched enough
Simpsons will agree with Peak Simpsons
right yeah exactly um when did you stop
watching The Simpsons when did you all
start watching The Simpsons when I stop
watching TV yeah pretty much focus on on
in the UK right
on Sky yeah paid uh broadcasting which
my dad bought because he wanted to watch
football matches yeah so it was like oh
we'll buy this and then the only reason
that you know the wife won't get angry
at me so it's for the family because
we've got other channels as well right
so we had we had that and um they used
to play four episodes uh a day from six
to eight pm damn so every single day
after school just chill on the living
room do whatever I need to do and just
watch four episodes of Simpsons yeah
every single day I remember I think it
was like on weekends they would do like
three or four episode runs yeah this is
crazy yeah it was great yeah I can
remember the exact moment for me that
the Simpsons died in my mind it's
actually like The Simpsons Movie I think
actually yeah
I remember like oh okay so wow Simpson's
got a movie that's a big [ __ ] deal I
haven't like at that point I hadn't like
watched you know I grew up with The
Simpsons but I wasn't like regularly
watching you don't realize it like
season like nine or ten is [ __ ] yeah
yeah you're just like oh this is funny
he
and then I remember like people [ __ ]
losing it over [ __ ] spider pig or
something oh my God I hated that and I'm
just like what
this isn't funny why is yeah white
people that was definitely the least
funniest part of The Simpsons that was
like there were many not funny parts of
this yeah that was like I remember back
when that came out people like quoting
it I'm like this is the pickle Rick of
my time you know it literally was yeah I
was just like why are people quoting
spider pig and it's not even spider pig
Ransom pickle Rick
dude I I [ __ ] love especially like
when we were probably getting in
Simpsons when all the best Simpsons
games were out yeah like hit and run one
of the arcades the arcade ones
oh my God that was a [ __ ] coin
guzzler that was Peak Simpsons right but
yeah I mean Simpson's great I mean this
is great what the [ __ ] is specs and
specs yeah specs and specs is a TV show
that sounds Australia it looks like a
kid's show it's a quiz show
um it's a music question it's like a gay
pride show no no no they just happen to
have a rainbow okay okay now Rainbows
are dope
but it's named after I think a uh uh a
Beach Boys song I think right but
basically it's this kind of it's kind of
like imagine like Qi right but yeah
except all of the questions and all of
the guests are the musicians okay this
is right up your ass yeah and obviously
you know I'm a [ __ ] music nerd right
so it's like that show was really cool
because not only would they get really
cool musicians on as guests but they
also like it was hosted by an Australian
comedian
um called Adam Hills
um and he had you know in any in each
team there would be like different kinds
of you know music themed like quizzes
and like that would also break into like
a talk show where they would like talk
about guests and stuff like that I think
one of my one of the weirdest segments
that they had was they had this quiz
early on in specs and specs called
musician or serial killer
and they'll basically what they would do
is they would show a black and white
picture and just by looking at the
picture of the person it's like a mug
shot like front face you would have to
guess is this a musician or a serial
killer that's also wow yeah and a lot of
the times I and and as a kid I watched
that and you know you'd play along
obviously because you you know there's
no [ __ ] prior knowledge or anything
this is before True Crime [ __ ] was a
thing right yeah yeah and so like it was
really weird that I swear the more
someone looked like a serial killer the
more likely they were more likely they
were a musician and vice versa I believe
it yeah and so there was stuff like that
there was another one where it was like
um they took song lyrics put them
through Google translate it's like some
Asian language and then translated it
back in English and then they would read
that out and you'd have to guess what
the song is and so like it was just like
really cool ideas for quizzes
that's a great idea for an after dark
question honestly I like him Honestly
though like I came up with like you know
I came up with so many like quiz ideas
and stuff like that for my videos
through shows like this yeah because it
was just like really interesting and fun
ways where you could kind of oh another
one where was like there was like an
exercise bike that was connected to a
vinyl player like a vinyl record player
right and you had to Pedal the bike at a
certain speed for the song to be able to
play oh that's cool you have to quickly
guess yeah yeah what the song is for
example it's just stuff like that sounds
good yeah it's a really really good show
Even if you have no idea about music
just the fact that it's like hosted by a
comedian who's really funny has a lot of
really cool musical guests and just like
the quiz segments are just really
creative yeah which is like really
really good show
um and then I guess top right is the
only Japanese show I put in Goku not Sky
basically every American uh you know
like uh punishment game remake remake
came from this okay so Silent Library is
one of the most famous ones these guys
came up with the first
um another one would explain what silent
libraries is Silent Library I guess so
basically everyone yeah Silent Library
basically is just again these guys
started first but basically you would go
into a public library sit around a desk
and then you would hand out uh like
cards you'd flip them over one person
would get the punishment and then they
would have to do a punishment but react
yeah silently yeah and these punishments
in this show were [ __ ] brutal I mean
Japanese TV shows is a big history yeah
adaptation for being yeah like Takeshi's
Castle is another show that I thought
about putting on here but he definitely
pushed the line in terms of like what
you can get away with it some of the
things that they did on this show were
like actual torture yeah like it's crazy
like uh one segment that they did was um
24 hour no reaction uh pie face
challenge where basically one of the
comedians in this group would live in
this like mock house and the entire time
for 24 hours the rest of the cast are
throwing like pies at his face and he's
not allowed to react for 24 hours what
yeah it's just [ __ ] like that it's just
being Pi boarded you're being High
borders for 24 hours straight insane
yeah it's it's insane another one was
like 24 hour tag so that would be inside
of a gymnasium and then randomly a dude
would pop up and if you got tagged by
them then you'd have to get punished for
24 hours it's just crazy I noticed in
Japanese TV when you've done your time
so to say you've done the the brutal
stuff and done all the you've put
yourself out there a bunch you get to be
the react Andy yeah when you become the
show you how become royalty in Japan's
comedy scene you get to react yep that's
that because that's that's who the big
dogs are yeah because they're on
everything every big Celebrity Face you
see yeah it's always the [ __ ]
in the corner of the screen they're all
the comedians that you see just in the
react corner of the screen they started
off doing [ __ ] like yeah so it's like
we've done our time we've done our work
so with the work their way off the
system man it's like hunting games and
maybe you get a successful
exactly but like on like honestly if
you're a YouTuber just watch episodes of
Goku not sky and it's just a treasure
oh yeah I mean that guy is the [ __ ]
oh yeah
but uh yeah so that's uh that's like one
of my favorite Japanese shows going on
also learn a lot of Japanese watching
that show as a child I believe it yeah
um and then Japanese quiz game Japanese
quiz game yeah exactly uh MythBusters
obviously everyone knows [ __ ] videos
Okay so this was assembly okay so this
was the original Adams Family TV show
from the 60s I was wondering why I was
in black and white yeah so this is on
the 60s this is this was this was during
a time where I had this like weird
obsession with watching a lot of old
films so I would like this was during
the time where I would be like so uh was
Citizen Kane actually a good movie I'm
gonna go and check it out right so I
would watch like citizen it was okay I
would I would watch Citizen Kane and
like all the you know the Orville films
and like all of the [ __ ] this is what
this is how you started your altar phase
yeah I was yes
I was like I'm not like those other kids
watching Breaking Bad [ __ ] off I'm gonna
watch Adam's Channel you mean let's cook
but um yeah I think what really was cool
about Adam's Family like the even though
this is [ __ ] what a 60 year old show at
this point yeah it's still [ __ ]
hilarious you know whenever you like you
know you watch Modern TV shows that
popped on the TV you're like this is
[ __ ] Whatever Whenever you for some
reason in a place and old TV shows come
on they're always so good yeah they are
I don't know if I'm like crazy but like
that one's just funny they must be good
in order to have still to still be still
survive yeah right yeah maybe it's like
Survivor bias of like well yes because
you're seeing the best of the best that
we remember right yeah cherish and made
sure we kept in HD I'm sure out of every
one Adam's family there was 20 really
shows but yeah like I mean what is
Adam's Family about I I just know the
name Adam's family is about comedy is it
a drama it's a comedy so Adam's family I
think it's based off a comic book series
or a book or something please confirm
Kai but basically it's about this really
[ __ ] weird family called The Adams
Family uh like very like Macabre and
like obsessed with like death and stuff
like that and they're just like a very
weird they were like the original like
we don't like the other families type of
family right
um so like they kind of want to be yeah
so there's like Gomez and like Morticia
and uh [ __ ] I don't know Uncle Fester
and like just characters like that where
it's just like you know there was just
like it was the weirdest cast of
characters they're human right yes
they're human but they're but they're so
weird and so obsessed in the Macabre
that they're almost not human I mean
there is a character that's also not
human but in other another
interpretation of the show they are
actually like yeah why do I think
they're vampires yeah other in other
versions of stories like the I think
Adam's family is yeah I think it borders
on like are they human or are they just
weird humans or are they non-humans
trying to live in a human is he Adams
can you look uh it was based on the
cartoon like oh a cartoon okay is it
public domain I can't remember if it is
I don't know to be honest but they've
done re a bunch of remakes of uh like
movies from like the 90s Adams Family
movie is [ __ ] hilarious and I think
recently uh Adam Sandler one right not
uh
Adam's Family one or is that a Dracula
movie I don't know
animated cartoon am I crazy am I mixing
yeah so like what I really enjoyed about
this show is that like it because the
characters are just so [ __ ] absurd
yeah it makes for some really really
unique comedic bits right um so like for
example like
um I don't know like uh Lodge for
example is this like almost like
Frankenstein's monster type of thing but
he's also the he's also the butler of
the family right and then there's also
another character called thing which is
just a disembodied hand that just crawls
around and emotes and there's been so
many remakes of it I think there's gonna
be a remake of there's like a new like
Netflix I think TV series based on
Wednesday Adams oh uh which is like the
youngest daughter of Adam's family or
something made by what's his name Adam
Sandler maybe my brain was Dumb and
thought Adam Sandler was in it because
it's The Adams Family yeah that's what I
was about to say but yeah
I thought we I thought that was like too
obvious
yeah but it's a real if you want like a
classic like funny like comedic uh show
then I I'd say Adam's family's still
like a lot of the episodes I think are
still really funny yeah did you ever
watch a thing too yeah oh yeah of course
what is it you know it oh okay oh okay
that's it that's it yeah did you ever
watch the Twilight Zone since yeah oh
yeah Twilight Zone I grew up with as
well but like I don't think Twilight's
always one of those shows where that I
would see it every now and then on TV I
wouldn't like religiously watch it like
Simpsons have you ever watched that TV
show that was like fact or fiction
and well the memes of that that guy
going like it's it's a lie I made it up
it's it's not true I made enough I lied
you know I think so that sounds like
[ __ ] dude what God damn it why does such
a [ __ ] patch oh no no no no wait wait
I know what you're talking about yeah
the guy in like in the Smoky room in the
Smoky room no I made it up yes okay no
now I know what you're talking about I
didn't know I think so I thought what I
didn't know that came from like a TV
it's uh uh beyond belief beyond belief
uh Jonathan
Frakes Beyond a belief I thought I don't
know I don't know why I just thought
that was like a History Channel show
yeah I thought so too yeah it's just
like a bunch of oh yeah and realized
you'd forgotten where you parked your
car ever gone mountain biking what do
you want to be when you grow up what's
the right tip have you called it oh yes
yes
this one's good I like that show that
was really good yeah
MythBusters I think we spoke about this
a little while ago yeah I mean I met
Adam Savage is great MythBusters is
[ __ ] awesome if you don't know what
MythBusters is Jerry take it away
MythBusters basically Adam and Adam
Savage and Jamie Hyman uh they basically
I think they used to work in like
Hollywood as like special effects uh
creators but they basically have like
two guys with really long science
backgrounds who basically take common
myths and scientifically prove whether
it's real or just a myth yeah um really
simple concept but because they go about
it in a scientific way it's really cool
to just see them be like all right so
there's the myths for example that yeah
um there's the myth for example that
like uh enough balloons can pick up a
human body off yeah so then they go out
and go all right how many balloons would
it actually take to pick up an average
human body off the ground and so they
would go through all this or like you
know another one was like um how many
layers of uh of glass could stop a
bullet yes for example there's also like
you know can salsa dissolve prison bars
yeah yeah just like
just like all like a uh floss like a
teeth floss yeah can it cut through a
steel bar for example it's so it's like
they basically take common myths or like
stuff you see in movies and they go is
like is that Capital fact it's basically
it's like uh you know the the
predecessor to crazy YouTube engineering
Channel yeah obviously I was going to
say this did science YouTube before
science YouTube yeah yeah absolutely
it's very it's very uh it feels very
nerdy yeah and it feels very you know
doesn't care if you don't like the show
or you don't like the style it feels
like they just wanted to make the show
and make it for them yeah and make it
the way they wanted it and blow stuff up
yeah it was it was one of the few shows
that managed to make science cool oh
yeah because whenever we think of
science engineering we just like [ __ ]
fall asleep because like why why should
I give a [ __ ] about chemistry or boring
or like you know [ __ ] sorry
the reason we give about chemistry is
Breaking Bad that's right but but now oh
you're telling me that chemistry can
blow things up and set things on fire
okay suddenly I care now just like like
in a lot of in a lot of the episodes
what I really enjoyed is the fact that
it was just purely Adam and Jamie just
being like
what if this would happen or like have
you ever thought about could this be
real like a one that's really good is
like um shell shock from grenades how
close like it's the uh the myth of like
if there's a grenade about to go off and
someone Dives on top of it then that
will save everybody else yeah and so
what they would do is they would like
out of ballistics gel that would create
a human shaped thing that would put it
on top of a grenade they would put
another human some distance away and
then they would see if that human being
dies yeah and it was just funny because
it was just an excuse for them to just
blow up a bunch of grenades I mean it's
it's funny because you you started those
the soft being like you know what they
did it for the name of science you know
they want to blow [ __ ] off yeah I was
just like talking to the safety third
guys I'm like I just realized they just
find like the most convoluted reasons to
find to find a reason to blow [ __ ] up
you know that's true and that's that's
MythBusters basically honestly and so
like oh you know a lot of like I [ __ ]
watch the show religiously it was like
my favorite thing to watch it's a great
TV show oh it's fantastic very well
yeah um editing any [ __ ] goes without
saying probably one of the best Cartoon
Network shows to come out I just love
edit nitty a lot I love the um I've got
the name of the uh this art style where
the the every character's lines are
always moving oh that's like like a
rubber hose no no rubber hose is more
like Disney like right oh like 30s
animations yeah it's like it's like a
it's like boiling lines or something
I love that the color palette oh yeah
nuts I mean and like just it's one of
those shows that where I feel the
original creators were just like what's
human anatomy yeah that doesn't exist
well tell us about the surgery what
happens Ed and Eddie's basically just a
Cartoon Network show from the 90s where
it's just two thousands is it 2000 it
was the 90s for sure it's 2000 I don't
know it's somewhere around there though
early 2000s where it's basically just
based in a cul-de-sac in everyday
America and it's just a bunch of kids
just [ __ ] doing random [ __ ] in the
cul-de-sac to try and get jawbreakers so
try and get jawbreakers so they do a
bunch of schemes to try and money to get
your
they love these draw breakers for some
reason and they'll do anything yeah and
it's great every every character is
great that it's just fun show the voice
acting is so good yes it aged really
well really really well the animation
style is so good there's a there's a
clip that recently I found on YouTube
that I've just been obsessed with again
and it's just this one episode where uh
Eddie uh this guy in the middle here if
you don't know Eddie is like he he
dresses up as like a demon uh like
character to try and convince Ed who's
the dumb guy to do a bunch of weird [ __ ]
so that he could like turn him into like
a freak to like earn it a freak Show and
there's one scene where he's just like
eat your mattress and then edges looks
at the bed and he's like okay
and then it double D this little guy Ed
comes in and it's just this scene of
just Edge [ __ ] eating this mattress
hole and it's the most like okay before
it was yeah it was just like good Lord
man he's just eating this mattress
um it's just the most absurdist humor
ever but it's really really [ __ ]
funny like one thing that like
re-remembering Ed Edd and Eddie makes me
realize is that our cartoons as weird
now no no
a little bit a little bit different way
yeah because I feel Eden Eddie kind of
falls into the same genre of cartoons as
like you know the remnants team yeah
they're in Stimpy where it's like so
absurdist to the point where it's almost
gross oh yeah the art style can be gross
at times yeah well I was just I'm just
thinking about it I'm like man I watched
a lot of weird [ __ ] as a kid this era of
Cartoon Network had some of the weirdest
television yeah it's like the Golden Era
of course oh yeah like Cow and Chicken
was another one where I'm just like oh
Cow and Chicken
like these shows are [ __ ] weird well
like if you put this on Adult Swim it
would totally just blend in oh
absolutely and I'm just like how did we
grow up with these cartoons that's so
[ __ ] weird what yeah like re-watching
some scenes of Ed and Nanny I'm like how
did I not get traumatized with some of
the [ __ ] I'm seeing right now like dude
yeah I would not show my kids
kind of group Vibe uh yeah I kind of did
um I was definitely like the the Eddie
type of character where I'm just like I
was just convincing other people to do
dumb [ __ ]
that makes sense yeah I definitely had a
friend who was like Ed yeah I was just
like anything I told him to do he would
do I think everyone every friend group
had an edge but that's the thing that's
what I think that's what I think was so
good about ednetty was that it was such
an absurdist like completely just like
out of the norm type of show but the
characters fundamentally were characters
that you could recognize whereas like
there was at least one character in edin
Eddie where you're like I have a friend
who's like that or I'm like that
um music as well oh do an intro opening
song
best one so good um do I have to talk
about Arthur we say it's God is Arthur's
got it if you don't know what Arthur is
just watch Arthur how would you even
describe our [ __ ] children's TV but it's
so good that an adult could probably
enjoy it yeah like it is literally made
for like five-year-olds but it's written
so well that like again like as an adult
you're like this is not it's it's so
weird because it kind of hides its very
adult themes in a very like friendly for
children type of way like I think it's
really I think Arthur is one of the best
shows when it comes to subtle writing
yeah where it's like before you realize
it this character has been built up to
be something that you can kind of be
like yeah I I get what you're going
through this is a really good episodes
yeah even when I was like 16 yeah come
back from school if Arthur was on I'd
watch Arthur oh yeah yeah I loved Arthur
speaking of Banger openings my life oh
my God one of the most legendary
cartoons
ingrained in my mind
etched in dude everybody thought they
were roster when they were listening to
this [ __ ] you know but uh very much a
shame that it's gone
you're a legend in our hearts it's it's
weird because I know I watched so many
episodes of Arthur I don't know if I was
just too young no you do yeah but I
don't like remember much of it it's it's
it's it's only through memes that I'm
like oh yeah this kind of happened
wearing the headphones yeah wearing the
headphones on top of the years yeah the
[ __ ] Arthur fist yeah that's Legend
what about that uh what was it it was
the the meme of um what's the [ __ ]
bulldog looking guy and he's like yeah I
I can't remember and he's like and he
puts the headphones in he just like
starts tripping
I love that one it's so good it's like a
really good show okay um the final two
ones are very Australian they look they
look Australian holy [ __ ] which one do
you want to start with okay uh Russell
coits all Aussie Adventures okay so this
was um do you know the show Katherine
Kim no it's like very like one of the
most quintessential Australian sitcom
shows very very funny we're only
important neighbors yeah well okay so it
was it was if if neighbors is like
number one Captain Kinsley number two
it's like one of the most beloved shows
um I thought about putting that on there
but this guy uh he's uh I keep
forgetting the guy's name the actor's
name but he's also a comedian Russell
Russell Coit is this character oh so
basically this is a parody of like a
kind of survival like Steve Owen
survival in Australia type of
educational shows except this guy whose
real name is not Russell Queen he's an
actor he plays this character called
Russell Coit who's like the most
stereotypical like yeah I'm a you know
I'm a survival expert out in Australia
and he tries to give and it's it's just
the sketch comedy show where it's
Russell Coit just trying to like kind of
tell you about like how this like this
is how you build a flyer in Australia or
like oh I just found a a a red belly
black snake here's how you like get rid
of it but it always ends up in the most
like horrific ways oh that's awesome
there's this one scene where he's
talking to some indigenous Australian
people
um and uh and and and he's kind of like
getting them to like you know teach them
about like how to like pick berries in
the wildlife and stuff yeah yeah
learning from them but there's this
reoccurring joke in in Russell Coit
where every time Russell Coit goes up to
someone and gives him a handshake
there's this one clip that replays every
single handshake so it's like it's just
it's almost like this stock image video
of just the close-up of the hands right
hand shaking these two white guys
handshaking and it plays every time
Russell Coit goes up to a new person and
gives him a handshake so this is one end
of one episode where he's talking to
these like indigenous Australians and
he's going up to handshake all of them
every time he goes into handshake it
just cuts to two white guys handshaking
every and it's like it's this show is
like that sounds like a meme yeah it oh
it is it dude like when people go back
so like adults or both oh yeah like it's
there were some there were some
instances where like it was very like
adult oriented where like he would
actually get hurt in the show but in
like a comedic kind of way but it was
just so incredibly funny because it's
one of the most perfect examples of just
really subtle comedy in like sketch
comedy shows right I don't know how well
it is aged today uh it might be you know
because I think this is from like the
late 90s I think early 90s okay today's
falling yeah yeah so some a lot a lot of
comedies of age Paul a lot of comedies
very
and another comedy that might have aged
poorly from that time is this one uh
it's called fat Pizza
um
so this is a show
so Kevin right our boy Kevin Kevin yeah
we [ __ ] bonded over the show again
the other day when we were when we were
in Australia because this is one of
those shows where I think everyone in
our age group watched this show all
right um so basically like you guys were
talking about Peep Show being like the
peak of like British cringe comedy yeah
this is probably the Australian
equivalent to it right okay so it's this
show about uh this this guy Paulie uh
who is this like uh Italian Australian
immigrant
um and it's basically about his
character he's like a pizza delivery guy
okay and he works at this like really
[ __ ] sketch pizza shop right this
really sketch neighborhood of Australia
um and it's basically just like the
daily shenanigans that he gets up to
where he has to deal with like these
like [ __ ] horrendous like Bogan
customers and like uh because uh Paul
Paulie this actor's name I think his
actual real name is Paul as well right
um and uh all of the cast members are
like you know uh Italian immigrants in
Australia or like uh like Lebanese
immigrants in Australia and it's just
like a lot of the it's it's very much
revolved around like kind of the
European and Middle Eastern immigrants
who migrated to Australia so a lot of
that kind of Comedy exists but you don't
have to be part of that race to
understand that comedy because it's so
ingrained in Australian comedy
um there's a really famous actress now
in Hollywood uh Rebel Wilson I think her
name is she started off in this show wow
Rebel Wilson she's not in this picture
oh no this is right there oh yeah so she
started off this was like the show that
made her famous in Australia she played
this character called Tula who is this
like [ __ ] obese-like girl who like
keeps ordering pizzas from this one okay
yeah okay and uh and and it's just like
it's it's really [ __ ] difficult to
explain but basically it's hearing you
guys talk about Peep Show is basically
the Australian equivalent of that take a
lot of cringe okay great great I'm
already interested
it's incredibly cringe it can be
incredibly offensive at times but also
really really funny yeah
um my Australian Brothers I know you get
you guys get your sarcasm your cringe
humor oh yes that's why like I would be
very interested to watch this yeah I
[ __ ] love it I feel this is the
perfect window into what Australian like
you know comedy and like Civilization is
kind of like super sexy
we live in a civilization because to be
fair I have been to some places in like
kind of outer Australia yeah where it
gives off this Vibe okay like these are
like they're exaggerations I think of
people that exist in real life yeah yeah
is is there a particular scene that uh
sticks out oh [ __ ] I don't know so like
uh like there's this one scene where
like uh Paulie gets like uh he has like
this uh friend who this Lebanese friend
uh called Habib
um and he like pisses off Habib for
doing something and then habib's just
like don't [ __ ] get in my way bro I'm
gonna call up all my cousins and then
he's just like how many cousins do you
have here and then five minutes later
there's just like over the hill there's
just these like 40 cars just full of
these Lebanese dudes that just like rock
up to the pizza shop and just start
beating the [ __ ] out of Paulie
and then and then Habib he he's like
this character he plays like this like
stereotypical like Lebanese Australian
guy so every time he takes off his shirt
it's just like completely just like full
of hair like you can't see any of his
skin at all and it just like kind of
plays into those stereotypes yeah but
not in like a way where it's like racist
if that makes sense it's just like a lot
of like just very you know
tongue-in-cheap like slapstick comedy
yeah yeah um that's very Australian all
right um and yeah that's uh my I don't
watch TV tonight how hard was it to make
this to be fair thinking about it now I
would probably replace maybe like
because I completely forgot about Top
Gear yeah yeah I'm like I mean I could
have put that down and I'm like what the
[ __ ] I watch so much [ __ ] Top Gear so
like yeah
we just try harder
yeah bottom gear but uh yeah there you
go so all right this episode is
sponsored by Babel now that the world is
opening up again I plan to travel to a
lot of different countries and explore
the world and thanks to Babel the
language learning app that sold more
than 10 million subscriptions there's an
addictively fun and easy way to learn a
new language whether you'll be traveling
abroad connecting in a deeper way with
family or you just have some free time
Babel teaches bite-sized language
lessons that you'll actually use in the
real world so it's considering that a
part of me is uh also German as well my
grandfather is German I wanted to learn
a little bit of German before I actually
go to visit family in Germany and Babel
was a really great app for that that was
15 minute lessons are the perfect way to
learn a new language on the go other
language learning apps use AI for their
lesson plannings but Babel's lessons
were created by over a hundred language
experts guys their teaching methods have
been scientifically proven to be
effective with Babel you can choose from
14 different languages including Spanish
French Italian and of course German hell
yeah plus Babel speech recognition
technology helps you to improve your
pronunciation and action there's so many
ways to learn with Babel in addition to
lessons you can access podcasts Games
videos stories and even live classes
plus it comes with a 20-day money-back
guarantee so what are you waiting for
start your new language learning Journey
today with Babel but guys right now when
you purchase a three month battle
subscription you'll get an additional
three months for free that's six months
for the price of free just go to
battle.com and use promo code trash
that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com code trash actually the
episode okay I was wrong Ed and Eddie is
1999. I was right all right all this
gone I already see that a bunch of these
I could have put on mine yeah exactly
hello we watch the same pop regular TV
shows yeah uh there's a couple I don't
know okay so starting from
these are these are so famous these are
literally some of the most popular shows
what's this one this is TV show
except I just framed it right this time
okay okay so so I guess we don't talk
about Pete's show yeah but I don't need
to talk about teachers Always Sunny Game
of Thrones Peep Show the good place uh
the original Justice League cartoon
shinobu uh Chernobyl sorry Battlestar
Galactica Black Mirror and Doctor Who I
am very surprised by Battlestar
Galactica yeah hold up what okay okay
why why why Battlestar life you've never
mentioned an interesting like sci-fi
stuff actually I I've realized it when
making this list but I've really [ __ ]
love Sci-Fi TV shows what the [ __ ]
you've never talked about yeah why have
you never like hinted at that what do
you mean okay this is the music is it
because that I already talked about
isakaya yeah you literally have never
given inclination that you give a [ __ ]
about I would take you more seriously if
you stop talking about music you didn't
talk about Dune huh you didn't talk
about doing much I [ __ ] love dude
dude's great dude's [ __ ] great I
think it's weird I think it's weird
right because I [ __ ] love uh sci-fi
but I just don't like Star Wars in terms
and that's like that's like that's like
whatever
you know
um so yeah walk is um
that's one of the few sci-fi shows oh
sorry one of the few uh television shows
that I actually got to complete when I
was in universities it's been a while
since I watched battle started Galactica
but I enjoyed the sternie the journey
from start to end basically if you want
a synopsis of the basic plot of
Battlestar Galactica it
uh humans have colonized the Galaxy and
there are like 13 colonies or some [ __ ]
like that and then they also built AIS
right AI robots and of course the AIS
had an uprising where the AIS I believe
they destroyed 12 of the 13 colonies
right yeah and the one remaining
surviving group of humans they tried to
find the last
mythical 13th colony which is Earth
damn damn but uh what makes it
interesting is of course these are like
the last 50 or 60 000 humans that are
just traveling through space trying to
find this last Colony uh but of course
they're on the run from the robots which
is like I think I believe they're called
cylons
um but the twist is that the robots the
cylons are so well programmed that there
are some cylons that have invaded this
Fleet right of humans but they're so
well programmed that they don't even
know that they're like a sleeper agent
right so and they look and sound and act
exactly like humans do and there's no
real way to detect them so basically
real Blade Runner [ __ ] huh that's a real
Blade Runner Yeah so basically it's just
[ __ ] sci-fi Among Us you know
Among Us is sci-fi
I guess it is so it's just Among Us you
know what Among Us it's just Battlestar
Galactica with the suits on okay how
many seasons it's battlestock I like to
get the game okay this is what I liked
about Battlestar galatzuka I believe
it's only four seasons and it finished
it up yes it's all finished it's a
complete story
um but what I found really what one
that's the one thing I really really
liked because that's why I've rarely
rarely finished TV shows yeah uh number
two
uh is that even though they have this
you know tension between like oh who's
who's a human who's a Cylon and
everything like that what I really liked
about the show is how it took this one
group of colonies and really explored
some really interesting ideas about what
would happen if you try to govern these
group of people right so basically they
kind of created a mini Nation right and
they they draw you in with like the
Space Battles and just the pew pew pew
and all that stuff like that but then
what's yeah yeah exactly but what kept
me interesting interested was in fact
the politics the politics behind behind
the spaceship the space this last space
colony and like what happened between
how you govern all of the humans and
everything like that on and I found that
way more interesting than the PPP and
like the Among Us part of the uh part of
the show I mean visual services so far
visuals can only take you so far
um it is just one of the best sci-fi
shows I've question then did you enjoy
Firefly
I have not seen Firefly okay because I
feel from if you liked Battlestar
Galactica I think you'd really like it
like have you seen Firefly yeah okay all
I know is I didn't finish yeah well they
made a movie called Serenity afterwards
which was supposed to be like the is
that the sequel is that really like a
sequel to it though no because I've seen
Serenity no it's not it's not a secret
what okay what is fireflies about
because all I know is like a space
spaghetti western or something like that
pretty much I'm trying to also remember
what it was about to be honest what
shouldn't find I just remember it being
really good because like I fireflies is
that one show that every person tells
you to watch yeah every every Sci-Fi TV
fan will be like Firefly best yeah I fly
best and I'm like but it was right by
Joss Whedon is that a good thing or a
bad thing anymore I don't know you know
like it's that thing you know okay it
kind of piss me off anyway but I guess
next okay while we're on uh sci-fi then
Doctor Who okay okay because me seeing
that immediately I was like holy [ __ ] I
forgot this show existed
but more broadly Doctor Who in the
Russell T Davis era okay yes so
basically I'm okay the thing about
Doctor Who fans is a lot of them are
just [ __ ] insufferable right they're
they're like the they're like the modern
Star Trek fans of old you know I think
same thing can be said for a lot of
these shows to be honest
I mean if a Show's good in some way yeah
long running it gets insufferable yeah
yeah I mean but like that's why I like I
really talk about Doctor Who but like
I.E it's a good show it's a really
really [ __ ] show and I [ __ ]
this I I said Battlestar galatzka is one
of the best sci-fi shows I've seen
Doctor Who is the best sci-fi shows it
is I I'll agree with that yeah yeah it
is in terms of like TV shows yeah it is
by far the show that tackles the most
weirdest ideas you could ever imagine
and it has like what I love about Doctor
Who is that every episode is like kind
of self-contained right every episode
tackles a different idea a different
time period a different place in space
and time right that's what that's what
makes it so [ __ ] interesting but then
it has like an overarching plot as well
that you don't necessarily need to watch
the beginning of Doctor Who to
appreciate it
you can't because no one knows where the
episodes are because the BBC dumped all
the episodes oh really well because back
in the day they thought why the [ __ ] are
we need to Archive this stuff oh [ __ ]
threw it away so I think a bunch of the
original original original logical
episodes are on you can watch them it's
like lost media yeah yeah
it's probably never going to be found
yeah and like to me like Doctor Who like
David Tennant's obviously my doctor but
I all I really really he's my doctor oh
God I sound like fun
I always like Doctor Who when I watched
it yeah but I just never got into it
like I would watch episodes here and
there you know the Christmas special
yeah yeah I think I started with like
because because David Taylor was the
10th season yeah
um and I think I started on like season
eight of season nine I don't remember
which one is this after like the who was
the doctor I don't remember whoever it
was before oh bless you whoever
I would know his face if I saw it
whoever it wasn't was it it was whoever
before it was before David okay that was
Christopher okay okay it was uh that was
the first one I watched where I'm like
oh what is this show and then I said and
then David tennan Doctor Who like season
10 where I was just like holy [ __ ] yeah
that's great he liked an amazing actor
yeah like like the Christopher Eccleston
also amazing actor as well
yeah I just think that it wasn't Matt
Smith's fault it was like Stephen
moffat's fault was it Stephen Moffat I
think it's Stephen Moffat I don't know
which season was the week John left the
BBC yeah I stopped watching Doctor Who
once I left the BBC okay yeah he bad no
loyalty to it anyway the Weeping Angels
episode is by far my favorite yeah
because that is probably the most
unnerving episode of Television ever
because like the the real beauty of
Doctor Who is I remember I remember
getting into dog two through Christopher
Eccleston and that was like when the
Russell T Davis era started
um and I remember watching like a few
episodes and I was like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
look at the monsters man look that's
that's literally this is literally the
worst CGI I've ever seen in my life so
I'm the CGI would make [ __ ] some of
the anime CJ it would make berserk 2017
look like [ __ ] God's here man that's
how bad the CGI was and I'm like this is
absolute garbage why does everyone hype
up Doctor Who but then I just like you
just keep watching and somehow the
writing is so compelling that it it
dances the perfect line between
campiness and you know just epicness
it's just great television because it's
it's something where if you just step
out for a minute and just look at it out
of context look at like something like
the Daleks or something and I'm just
like and you're just like why uh why is
this guy pointing a light at a talking
washing machine or extermining why is it
got a [ __ ] suction cup look [ __ ]
[ __ ] it looks [ __ ] ridiculous right
but that just shows how [ __ ] good the
writing is and the actors are of this
like Doctor Who world right and that
yeah there's just there's just a certain
magic where technically it is also a
children's show but it turns everyone
who watches it into a child oh yeah well
it turns you it gives it turns you back
into that point in life where you didn't
question things too much you just saw
something cool on TV and you're just
like wow that's that's that's scary you
know and yeah
always go to the [ __ ] Doctor Who
Museum in Cardiff yeah really yeah
because a lot a lot of uh Doctor Who's
shot in Wales oh really sorry I mean
Cardiff they have a ton of like a big
Museum or something I remember oh my God
my school used to drag me and I was like
[ __ ] hate this I don't like doctor
here I I also have a family guy Museum I
also thought
I also thought it was really genius the
writing that they Incorporated I guess
for the TV show where like at the end of
each season like when the doctor dies
quote unquote like he's just like no he
doesn't die it's just another version of
him dying and that's just like a great
way to just be like all right next
season who who wants to be the doctor
yeah who wants to be the doctor I also
think it's a good way to like reset the
house yeah to one freshen up and it just
resets the ongoing story because the
thing is even though there's like one
there's one massive ongoing story which
is like the doctor tries to find his
home planet you know but then every
iteration of a doctor who has their own
kind of self-contained story with their
own characters their own Side characters
within their own self-contained story uh
I just think uh I just think uh yeah
David sounds amazing David is [ __ ]
amazing I mean he's just an amazing
actor and Jessica Jones he's insane [ __ ]
you know like I'm has he been in more
roles aside from Doctor Who and Jessica
Jones I think he does a lot of theater
yeah so I think he he doesn't do as much
TV I think he's theater trainer right
yeah
I think he I think he does a lot of
theater yeah as much on the side of uh
yeah he's really good yeah uh anyway
Doctor Who it's worse
let's talk about Game of Thrones I
wanted to talk about that first okay
going going off the Breaking Bad uh Game
of Thrones going off the Breaking Bad
Point okay okay this is definitely going
to be a hot take
I thought season 8 was the best what are
you gonna say I prefer the later seasons
of Game of Thrones [ __ ] oh God genuinely
okay genuinely do you know how bad oh
that is I I was tired right we've been
filming all day that woke me the [ __ ] up
I will tell you how bad of a take that
was I haven't seen a single episode of
Game of Thrones and I know that was gone
that's how I know how much of a bad
thing that was like it's like I want the
one written by uh the people who didn't
read the book and I want Ed Sheeran in
it and I want people
yeah Ed Sheeran was in an episode like
it is it is just bad oh my God what do
you like about that what explain
yourself okay okay you're on trial right
now okay I'm on trial right now like I
said like I said about breaking bad it
felt like tell me the season it got good
first and then tell me why
um I mean I mean I think it was always
good okay well it was always good but it
just got when I really when I really got
invested was around season six my
favorite season was about season seven
uh I mean season seven the One season
where like oh everyone got pissed off no
no that's season eight oh that's season
eight and even even I'm like okay season
eight okay that's that was that was that
was seven that was a little blunder that
was a little blunder right there all
right but I I okay because here's the
thing right going back to my Breaking
Bad energy I know I got the entire world
watching me right now I have got the
entire [ __ ] world watching me right
now and then people will wonder man why
is the subreddit spiking
after this episode goes live you just
here I can understand the Breaking Bad
take you this one feels irredeemable I
can't wait to read the comments on this
episode go on
like I said Game of Thrones seasons one
to four is almost perfect television
it's [ __ ] fantastic yeah characters
are well written well defined the World
building is amazing and everything like
that
um like I said seasons one to four I
didn't really have any emotional
attachment to it it's literally George
RR Martin's baby at that point that's
he's he did everything at that point no
I no no I I agree so how do you how do
you what how do you get more attached
when [ __ ] HBO takes over with their
generic Riders because one thing that I
[ __ ] love one aspect I love in any
media is when you have different kind of
different kind of aspects and cultures
clashing together right that's kind of
like why I've really I'm invested in the
MCU where you have you know Wizards and
superheroes and now you know [ __ ]
Cosmic God people all existing within
the same universe and that's that's kind
of that's because that's what drew me
into Game of Thrones originally and what
I [ __ ] my favorite parts of Game of
Thrones was in the later Seasons when
you finally saw this these different
worlds that have been built up in
seasons one two and three and four and
stuff like that you finally saw all
these worlds kind of colliding in
together and having some really really
cool moments is the writing as good [ __ ]
no okay I will fully admit the writing
is not as good but was it [ __ ] badass
seeing the Dothraki riding over a hill
with a [ __ ] Dragon like [ __ ]
burning the Lannisters hell yeah that
was bad [ __ ] ass and I will like
defend that [ __ ] all right I think it it
it built it up so well and then just
[ __ ] unraveled the coil and then just
threw a bunch of cool battles at us to
distract our pretty little brains I
think it it squandered everything it
built up I I think it was about politics
and then it suddenly became about Ed
Sheeran and shitty battles and just
rushing it no I will totally agree it it
was
Seasons you Game of Thrones was two
completely different shows I mean that's
I I fully admit it was two completely
different shows and technically I should
out of like every bone in my body think
that the first four seasons are the
better ones but I'm following my heart
and my heart says you cool dragons for
burning stuff oh look at the dragons
burning the ice zombies isn't that so
cool oh God if you wanted an easy card
gun
yes okay yes let's get the [ __ ] out of
here with this [ __ ] tape I actually [ __ ]
take when do you okay when do you think
Game of Thrones Go Bad season five
season five yeah season five started
falter what was it what was what
happened in season five again I felt
like season five
I can't remember exactly I do remember
because I had been watching Game of
Thrones weekly since season three season
three was amazing season four was just
[ __ ] god tier yeah one of the most
iconic moments in the series uh just it
was like headies and four season three
season four as well I had the one fight
between the two people oh memorable oh
yeah yeah yeah um I love how he just
fully understood no yeah you know it's
that scene
um I remember that scene actually gave
me PTSD like what yeah how seeing a
character and this happens a lot by the
way but there's there's one particular
scene where you saw a character that you
really liked I mean you got emotionally
attached to seeing them like get killed
off in such a gruesome way hmm it just
actually gave me like an emotional like
guttural reaction yeah me too yeah and
it was isn't that a good thing though it
was horrible no no that's why it's good
though yeah I know I know they managed
to get that emotion out of you yeah I I
totally agree it was a different thing
don't do that yeah I don't know man I
don't know what characters I'm just like
what the [ __ ] that doesn't [ __ ] do it
again yeah and then like you know end of
season three as well what happened at
the end of season three one of the most
famous one of the most iconic TV moments
of all time yes
no you've heard of it you know you have
heard of it yes don't know anything
about it I know you don't but the only
thing I know about Game of Thrones is
it's Lord of the Rings with tits yeah
like like that's what people have told
me like people are dumb yeah like I said
I'm like you sold me like I said perfect
television
is a pretty recent one I feel like I've
seen this if you've gone on Netflix
you've seen this yeah yeah yeah it's
pushed it down everyone yeah this is
this is a Netflix show again only four
seasons
um it passes itself off as a comedy but
I don't really think it's a comedy so
the whole premise of the good place is
uh you know the good place is an analogy
for heaven of course okay so all of
these people have died and gone to
heaven
except for Kristen Bell who is the main
character in the good place uh she wakes
up in heaven right but when they tell
her like when I talk about her life
story and identity in person she was and
everything she did on Earth she realizes
that she's up in heaven by mistake okay
and the whole premise initially is her
trying to convince everyone that yes she
is this person who they all believe her
to be and she is a good person that
belongs in heaven right uh and that's
that's that's how the premise of the
story you know starts off and honestly
like I the good place started off as a
show that was just you know I just put
on in the background as background noise
I was like this isn't bad but this is
like good enough where I'm like I can
have it on the background just as white
noise to be like oh it's it's all right
it's all right it's it's a I like the
concept of like them going up to heaven
and everything like that it was like a
nice little Chemistry Between all the
characters and everything like that it
was okay
um and then without spoiling what
happens a big twist happens at the end
of the first season
that I like I did not know that it was
going to be that kind of show where it
turned the good place into just like a
kind of like wacky sitcom comedy into
these characters have a motive and
they're going to try to achieve
something and I have an end goal and you
get to see not only the the character
progression but it kind of just becomes
an entire Adventure right like Bojack
right like lulls you in with the funny
animals and just hits you with the
depression yeah yeah exactly but yeah
one one thing I [ __ ] loved about the
good place is one like it is a whole
complete story right when you when you
think of most sitcoms sitcoms don't
really have stories you know what I mean
sitcoms are just okay you know you're
self-contained it's it's kind of like oh
which character's gonna get with which
character oh is Rachel gonna get with
Ross oh Rachel go with Ross by the way
end of friends bye-bye I really hope
that wasn't going to I hope nobody cares
about that spoiler to be fair I was
close to putting friends on them that's
a good show
but the point is there isn't really an
ongoing story yeah this one had comedic
moments right but what it what what
really shines in my eyes is the ongoing
story and within this ongoing story it
tackles so many issues about the
afterlife about religion about morals
and it's one of those shows where you
get you get in on the laughs and you
know you say Bojack was about depression
I was surprised you didn't put Bojack on
by the way I thought I thought someone
would put Bojack yeah I don't know I
didn't you know I feel like everything's
been said about it yeah yeah but like
the good place is one of those shows
where you end and it's just like such a
thing it leaves you with like such a
warm feeling where it feels like
wholesome yeah it's it's it's I've
watched it through osmosis
it's it's not just it's not just
wholesome but it gives you like a good
life message at the end of it and you
feel like damn you know get sort of the
opposite of Bojack the neutral yeah
[Laughter]
there are two sides of the coin yeah
yeah exactly where you know it you you
leave the end of good place and I've
never just like I've never cried over a
leave in a good good place do I believe
in a good place do you leave in a good
place do you leave in a good place well
I won't spoil oh what the ending of good
place is thank you but uh but you know
it's I've I've it's all right yeah it's
rare that I cry over a sitcom okay but
the sick the good place is the only
comedy that's ever made me cry at the
end of it just because seeing these
characters come to the end of their
Journey their adventure and just seeing
how each character story ended was just
so gratifying and I was just genuinely
happy for everyone in the story amazing
[ __ ] shot uh just season one just
wait till the end of season one uh yeah
what do you want to talk about now let's
do Black Mirror Black Mirror okay why
Black Mirror why Black Mirror because
okay okay before before we start talking
about that yeah do you think if let's
say uh for example like Australia Game
of Thrones has three Banger seasons and
like three dog [ __ ] Seasons that it kind
of levels it out because like Black
Mirror is that well I actually prefer
the later Seasons [ __ ] I'm kidding I'm
kidding okay
I was about to go bald from the race she
is great because I have bad enough taste
that that would be actually believable
no I wouldn't believe it
no like okay let's the British ones
again
when it was in our control it was
amazing three was actually pretty good
as well I will say three three I think I
only watched up until three
well I mean season one and two I mean
season two is just oh Season Two Season
three fantastic White Christmas yeah I
mean I think uh season one and two and
half the season three is like that's
that's all the Black Mirror that exists
in my mind but to me Black Mirror is
everything that I look for in a TV show
and I think part of that part of that is
because I just like how much I respect
the original creator of Black Mirror
yeah Charlie Brooker yeah one of my
biggest influences of all time seeing
him seeing him go from like a TV show
where he basically does what I do and
review movies and events and stuff like
that go and see him do Black Mirror was
just such a I actually didn't know it
was fine huh I actually didn't know it
was by Charlie you didn't you didn't
yeah no you don't know he's just
incredibly [ __ ] talented
um and just seeing the [ __ ] wild ass
ideas that Black Mirror had in season
one and two and three I mean it kind of
just it it so like accurate that it kind
of mirrors a lot of things that have
happened post the uh oh yeah Post Post
Release right there's a reason why like
Black Mirror is almost like in our
vocabulary with explaining like Tech
that scares us yeah oh yeah everything
is described and it's [ __ ] annoying
but anything that is scary and tech oh
that's very Black Mirror it's one of the
most like perfect commentaries I think
yeah of this generation basically it's
yeah it's the it's such a perfect meta
commentary on just the world in general
it is now yeah I use meta right this
time
but uh yeah I don't I don't really know
what else I can say about it I feel like
anything to meant like if attack the
scares you that should be it watch it
don't don't look anything up do not
watch anything go into it you'll have a
great time yeah because if I didn't put
Black Mirror on it's like I I I think
Charlie Brooker took such inspiration
from Twilight Zone right because that's
the only other like goat Anthology
series that I can think of
goatsology did I use ghosts right there
don't follow me that makes sense yeah
because like I it's I actually really
really [ __ ] love Anthology series oh
yeah yeah when it's done right like I
love that robots
can we put love can we talk about love
death and robots for a bit because you
need to watch Love death and robots I
think we actually spoke about it on a
podcast not too long ago yeah we
definitely recommended it because it's
so uh because we all watched season
three oh yeah I'll watch season yeah I
feel like Joe watch season three oh okay
yeah we've talked about too much TV no I
mean love death and robots season three
Banger season one Banger season two you
know yeah has has its Sparks yeah yeah
season three is really fun season three
is great yeah I just love seeing the the
thing the thing I love about Anthology
series is just seeing so many different
ideas experiments put into one it's so
experimental you know this is literally
the opposite of a show like you know
Breaking Bad you know where it's just
like this is just so many different
ideas that are packed into different
shows and it doesn't need to be a 10 out
of 10 Banger every time sometimes you
have like a little bit of lull but what
I what I appreciate always an anthology
series is that someone has something to
say and they have yeah it's always fresh
yeah and they have one chance to say it
and so it's it's always like it's always
is interesting especially when they have
like when they're like different
directives or different cinematographers
for episodes yeah completely unique feel
to each one oh yeah yeah exactly I mean
like Black Mirror Has some really iconic
episodes that I think are like must
watches yeah like white Christmas being
one like Christmas amazing yeah uh the
[ __ ] uh my favorite episode of Black
Mirror is probably like the American
Idol parody one the oh that was in
season two I believe yeah [ __ ] I forgot
the name of that episode I forgot the
name of the episode
I like that one as well with like the
wife who like gets the uh AI yeah oh no
she gets the dead husband and her
husband dies she got a husband like doll
yeah that's like gets her like memories
and he like slowly learns like the post
memories yeah that one's creepy
I can see Japan doing that yeah is that
scary is that scary that I see Japan no
absolutely absolutely that's so Black
Mirror
the sex toys be like yeah so so uh you
have three left which one do you want to
talk about all right let's go with
Always Sunny first I mean literally the
ghost actually I feel like Sunny is like
the most American Comedy sitcom yeah and
Peep Show is the most British yeah yeah
definitely oh you wouldn't say Big Bang
Theory
you wouldn't say How I Met Your Mother
oh Malcolm in the Middle
I I realized like watching things like
always sunny and uh Peep Show and
everything like that maybe I just like
to see awful people do awful 100 it's
just like awful people just funny right
exactly I mean that's essentially what
like people sure is not to boil it down
and really like dilute it but like yeah
it's the same awful people but just
British version yeah yeah exactly and
it's just like a lot of a lot of let's
say Peep Show storylines I could easily
see happening in order yeah but just
like the the dynamic would be completely
oh yeah you know what I mean right where
it's always sunny again is just uh the
five most awful people in this world
just doing awful things and having awful
[ __ ] ideas and trying to like win in
this world it's one of the funniest
sitcoms and long running for a reason
yeah yeah the only reason I think it's
kind of hard to get into is the first
season first four seasons yeah we're in
like a four by three aspect ratio and
look a bit weird yeah oh really I don't
know why also I think the first season
is good but the second season is when
they introduce Danny
and that's when it goes from a good show
to a [ __ ] great show because I think
Danny DeVito adds so much to their
chemistry yeah and what I love about
Always Sunny is if you look at like any
of the outtakes and everything like that
is that you can tell that so much of
this is just [ __ ] improv yeah right
there are so many lines It's Always
Sunny that you're like where the [ __ ]
did this come from and you know that
they just [ __ ] made it up on this
it's so good though it's so weird I
don't think I've actually sat down and
watched like a full episode oh my God
I've seen so many Clips because it's so
[ __ ] iconic there's like there's so
many like I could have thought about
putting this but it felt so wrong in no
sense because I'm like I think this is
my favorite but there's so many American
sitcoms that are like occupy the same
space in my mind like Arrested
Development not the new season it was
just really [ __ ] funny uh what are
some other really good American sitcoms
that are very adult humor they're really
well written communities really good as
well Curb Your enthusiastic because yeah
it's really good as well yeah I think
Sunny is always always sunny is like the
best it's the best out of all of them
for me
um
um yeah I don't know it's just don't be
sad when it ends up I'm I'm surprised
that it's gone on for this long honestly
well they renewed it for like what two
more seasons I think at least two more
yeah do you think they just did 11 or 10
yeah so I can't remember so many [ __ ]
good meme ball moments as well you dumb
[ __ ] I love that one yeah it's just
like sometimes you have you have a
moment where you're watching these
people do these awful things and you're
just like [ __ ] do I kind of relate to
what one of the characters is saying
because it's like that's the problem is
it's been a few characters you're they
are not remotely like but it's like
audience alike I actually like this guy
no no you're not supposed to you're not
supposed to like them you're like [ __ ] I
can actually like kind of kind of I just
kind of like them I mean it's just like
it's it's so it's so awful that it's
like [ __ ] amazing I don't know
[ __ ] you have to watch it uh I will
just just watch always watch any
episodes out of context and I think
you'll be all right but I think that's
the thing is like I've only seen Clips
out of context and it's still funny yeah
yeah exactly because I think all I think
all they do is just like what would
happen if we just put these four or five
characters into a situation and then
they just like let the characters act
out the situation kind of feels like an
improv class in some ways right but
because they've worked together so long
they kind of like know each other's
beats and everything like oh yeah like I
do not know how they film some of this
without [ __ ] laughing
all right okay two left let's do
Chernobyl I mean I love this series I
thought about putting it on yeah I was
like I don't know is it because it's too
good it's too good you know how like you
said Breaking Bad is too polished like
this is the most polished and clean TV
show that is just unarguably amazing
when I first saw this and and I haven't
seen this but when I first saw pictures
of this I thought it was like a
documentary series no yeah uh I mean
yeah I mean I mean it's not a
documentary series but obviously based
on real events yeah you actually believe
that it's based on real events yeah it
is it is it's one of those stories yeah
[ __ ] what happened
yeah bro when when they were writing
Chernobyl in real life bro they they
[ __ ] knew what they did they would
make some great television man yeah
but what I love about shinobu obviously
it's based on real life but it's one of
those stories that happened in real life
that is so [ __ ] insane that it's you
kind of watch this and you're like wow
this is an insane story oh wait this
actually [ __ ] reality is strange
non-fiction yeah you can't actually
believe that some of the [ __ ] that
happened in Chernobyl actually happened
here and yeah it's just like I said it's
just such a perfectly crafted TV show I
think the reason I've really liked
Chernobyl uh is because it's only like
it's a mini series it's so so short yeah
like how many episodes is it five
seconds
oh wow yeah it is it is not much you can
watch it in a day or two
um two evenings it is just amazing you
will not regret okay I think yeah I
don't know I haven't met a single person
who watched this TV show that didn't
sing its Praises because like the thing
the thing I loved about it is that one
one thing that I normally don't like
about let's say biopics or you know
shows about real life events is that
there's nothing thing there's nothing to
keep me coming back because I already
know the ending because it happened
right yeah because it happened but it's
the journey yeah yeah no no no like it's
it is about the journey you're right but
sometimes my brain like my brain is like
I need something to keep me coming back
every week yes but I think with biopics
what's so like interesting and unique
about them is that you can give a lot
more context in a human sense to the
events and the characters involved in a
sense yeah yeah exactly I also think
that's the reason why a lot of biopics
are just movies yeah right because it's
just like one clean package because you
know what's going to happen most of the
time right but what what I what like
drew me into Chernobyl immediately and
kept me going to the end that made me
appreciate the journey because the
journey was amazing but the the one
thing I think it did perfectly was it
set up this mystery right so this power
plant spoilers this power plant
basically explodes in Ukraine [ __ ]
alcohol
it's only the most devastating nuclear
disaster exactly history and within like
the first episode they set up this
concept of this is impossible it is
impossible for a nuclear explosion to
happen on this scale it is so impossible
that when it actually exploded people
didn't even believe that you know it was
it happened it was because of the
nuclear reaction right no that's that's
that's that's that was part of like the
incompetence of the uh higher-ups back
then where where they were sending
people to check on the nuclear reactor
to check on what caused this explosion
and people were like oh there's [ __ ]
bits of nuclear debris everywhere and
they were like I don't believe you go
check yourself and and so of course
everyone who checked would would die
yeah because they would be exposed to a
lethal a lethal dose of radiation yeah
um and so he sets off this mystery and
that mystery like continues throughout
the entire series and that's what kept
me coming back was just not only just to
see what happened but there was this
mystery that I wanted to see how they
resolved this because I genuinely didn't
know and I genuinely wanted to know
that's just something impossible I feel
Chernobyl the Chernobyl event is one of
those things where everyone knows the
name of it and everyone knows what
happened but very few people actually
know how it happened how or why yeah
it's also really eerie the series like
it it's always really like slow like
kind of violin eerie music that Creeps
in yeah at no point is it even remotely
happy it's like depressing all the way
through yeah and like the cinematography
as well in this isn't sucking fast it is
stunning yeah like watching this is just
a treat all of the actors are amazing
yeah um I think the only thing that it
could do better is that it could be like
maybe it's like a bunch of British
actors so it could be like Russian to
make a little more believable I didn't
really need it I felt like it was just
great like yeah you know it was good it
was just like and I think I think
Chernobyl has made like by itself made
me just afraid of just the sound of a
geiger counter there's yeah like the way
they use the Geiger counters sounds you
know it's it's literally like scarier
than a horror movie yeah right that is a
horror movie yeah exactly where there's
I think there's a scene where
um these guys are like in like the sewer
or something trying to figure out where
how to get in this nuclear power plant
and the bottom out yeah from the bottom
up right and you see you just hear the
geiger counter and all you hear is the
geiger counter and then since they're
wearing like full suits you don't hear
them say anything you just hear the
breathing and the guide counter and with
those two elements alone they're able to
create such a [ __ ] tense a terrifying
atmosphere and it's just it's just [ __ ]
it's insane amazing television you will
not regret it uh and I just finally
finally Justice League I get to talk
about Justice League did not expect this
one I was kind of expecting considering
you are like a big MCU guy yeah yeah yes
so I mean it's not MCU though
yeah I mean this series is a banger I
will admit this straight up as a bank
yeah you know so I don't think I ever
watched this dude this [ __ ] whenever it
got came on TV felt like a [ __ ] treat
it was never on it was it was [ __ ]
amazing and I I agree it was never on TV
but every time every time it did come on
in the UK I watched the [ __ ] out of this
right and like I like I got a confession
I'm like not a massive fan of like the
DC Superheroes you know you're a Marvel
guzzling I'm not even like a I wasn't a
fan of like the mark actually
you know I grew up with like the
Spider-Man cartoon
you literally eluded the tell us last
couple seasons of Game of Thrones to the
MCU earlier because like I don't know
why I just always thought like the DC
um characters were just kind of boring
you know Superman was kind of just two
Spanish boys
Superman's boring Wonder Woman's boring
Superman is just a dude Green Lantern is
like who Okay Batman's obviously go dude
flashes like like in most iterations of
Batman I was just like this is this is
kind of just boring he's just like he's
just edgy he's dark he's good in this
that's uh the reason I [ __ ] love this
Justice League is every character who I
normally hate in their own individual
media every character in this is a
[ __ ] Banger like they they they made
Batman like Batman by himself I never
found interesting Batman in a squad of
superheroes where everyone's got [ __ ]
super powers and yeah Batman's the most
badass out of all of this group [ __ ] yes
okay I bet I became a Batman Sim because
of the Justice League right uh because
of the Justice League cartoon and also
like I think like Superman is a like a
way more interesting character in here
in most of what most of like the films
I've seen betrayed because he's just
like what I love about him here is that
he feels like the father of the group
you know he really cares about everyone
deeply and like he's he's like he's
Batman's like the Rogue right in this
group but he's still like really really
good friends with Batman as well and you
can see a lot of a lot of The Chemistry
Between the group really grow and
develop as characters as from the series
beginning to the series then because I I
remember I was like I really liked the
Justice League cartoon and I was like
was that a kid thing was that a kid
thing yeah it was I a dumb kid and I
remember what re-watching it like two
three years ago so it was actually
pretty recent
um re re-watching like a few seasons I'm
like damn this is this is a genuinely
good and I think it's like my favorite
superhero cartoon show that I remember
growing up I mean yeah it's other than
that they have the other ones like Teen
Titans Teen Titans everyone yeah
everyone talks about Batman everyone
talks about Batman Batman is actually
really [ __ ] Batman's kind of go to
that actually is the Batman TV series
yeah yeah the Batman the animated TV
series yeah I know I know it's Mark
Hamill but yeah
um I I way prefer Justice League just
because I love it yeah I I loved the
group dynamic and it was one of those
shows where you watch this and you see
the modern iteration of Justice League
and you're like man what [ __ ] went
wrong you had a you had the perfect
template right there right there wow
um yeah the flash I'd never heard of The
Flash before and I [ __ ] love that he
was kind of like the wild wacky kid in
this one uh yeah [ __ ] every every
character in in Justice League is I
don't even remember these names the
other one well I can't remember the
other the birdish woman I come from Poco
a hot girl I never liked hot girl that
doesn't sound like a real
they gave all back then because
obviously like the [ __ ] 19 [ __ ]
50s whenever they made these comments
all the [ __ ] powers to the girls yeah
one of them no that's more that's my
smaller but actually one of my favorite
arcs involved like Hall girl which is
what basically I I really is it Hawkeye
or am I just like making [ __ ] out I
really hope it's a girl and she's a hawk
but it's when her species actually like
invades earth right that's one of my
favorite movie arcs uh sorry Justice
League's like where her entire species
invades Earth and basically just takes
over and creates this dystopian Society
uh that's the Justice League have to
overthrow I'm glad to accept Alberto of
Lords
the birdemic because I I I I say bird
girl and I'm just like wait isn't isn't
that just like well it's not just like
bird guy from uh [ __ ] Rick and Morty
I really hope
I don't know Batman sounds way cooler
than Hawk girl I don't know what it does
maybe because I got a picture of Batman
in my head
who's my fault maybe I'm the problem
here it doesn't sound real but it does
have you seen that edit where they take
the Batman theme and then they edit out
the bats in it so it's just man
man I need it
I need to hear that it's such a stupid
edit but I just I don't know why it's
just so funny why is that why did that
pop in your mind I don't know right
that's the funniest thing I've heard all
day I mean who touched So Gone I think
overall yeah I mean Game of Thrones I
actually died I mean I already want to
see like a few new shoes yeah I know I
was always interested and I I really
want to watch it and but like good play
sounds good as well honestly if I could
recommend one show that's like a show
that gels with me the most on this one
it'd probably be good place like okay
yeah Chernobyl I think is the best show
out of this but depressing technically
the good place I just like it was such a
surprise to me I didn't I didn't expect
it to be that good okay
um yeah well there it is our TV takes
our trash station can you tell us that
we're normal TV viewers uh yeah uh
recommendations fantastic let us know
you know maybe tell us in like a tweeted
us or go to the subreddit and let us
know that you watch don't do it anyway
and you liked it because I'd like to
know if my recommendation or one of
these boys recognition was helpful to
you yeah yeah
but hey look at all these patrons though
they watch TV and they have good teasing
TV hopefully yeah but uh hey if you'd
like to support the show then go to our
patreon patreon.com trash taste follow
us on Twitter send us your memes or your
3x3s on the subreddit yeah and if you
hate a fast listen to us on Spotify yeah
and if you and if and if anyone says
that I only like Game of Thrones season
seven because there's incest in it get
the [ __ ] out there's incest in all of it
yeah I know that's what I'm saying
that's what I'm saying okay
this is
one where it's getting banged in the
tower and he's like wait is that a
brother sister
all right see you later bye
foreign
[Music]